Hey, wow. Look at you guys. Hey, by the way, what they don't know is, the audience doesn't know, is that we had already started a cold open, and Rob and Bennett were rolling yet. Remember that? Oh, God. Remember we were about to go?
嘿，哇。看看你们。嘿，顺便说一句，他们不知道的是，观众不知道的是，我们其实已经开始了一个冷开场，罗布和贝内特当时正在录制呢。还记得吗？哦，天哪。还记得我们准备上场的时候吗？
And then Rob goes, a rolling. So it's a lukewarm, lukewarm opening here. Now we're ready for all this warm. It's from Arbior. Welcome to Smartless. Somebody just had a bacon, egg, and cheese sandwich for breakfast. And it wasn't me. And it wasn't you, and it wasn't J.B.
然后罗布说，正在录制。所以这是一个不冷不热的开场。现在我们准备好迎接所有这些温馨了。这是来自阿比奥尔的节目。欢迎收听 Smartless。刚刚有人早餐吃了培根鸡蛋起司三明治。而且不是我。也不是你，还不是 J.B。
and it wasn't her surprise guest, although I don't know what they had. Hi, everybody, it's Will. And we're back with Smartless. Oh, my God. I'm having my tea. I got to catch up with you. Oh, boy.
也不是她的神秘嘉宾，虽然我不知道他们吃了什么。大家好，我是威尔。我们又回到了 Smartless。哦，天哪。我正在喝茶。我得跟你们叙叙旧。哦，天哪。
That's so much. Will, did you make the bacon egg cheese sandwich? What does it make mean? Oh, no. Makes me. Do you go down to... You know what? Can I mention it?
这太多了。威尔，培根鸡蛋起司三明治是你做的吗？那是什么意思？哦，不。是我做的。你会去……你知道吗？我能提一下吗？
I ordered it from Leora. Oh, that spot. I love that spot so much. My goodness. I feel like they're leaving a lot. little money on the table by staying in such a small spot i know i agree always booked up and they're buried in that uta building yeah and sean have you been there no it's unbelievable there have you had the frozen coffee jb no but nothing sucks there it's a joke i can't have it right now because it'll send me to the moon i'll be i'll be
我是从莱奥拉那里订的。哦，那个地方。我太喜欢那个地方了。我的天哪。我觉得他们留在那么小的一个地方，白白损失了不少钱。我知道，我同意。总是预约满员，他们藏在那栋 UTA 大楼里。是啊，肖恩，你去过那里吗？没有，太不可思议了，你去过吗？你喝过冰咖啡吗，J.B.？没有，但那里没有一样东西是逊色的，太绝了。我现在不能喝，因为它会让我飘上月亮，我会，我会
but i'll bet you that bacon egg and cheese sandwich was slathered with uh just real tasty creams and Well, no, it was more like the bread had been perfectly toasted, so it was like... Where it's just, it's got a little edge to it that's got some chewing, some crunch, but the center is so soft. Yeah, the cheese was so velvety. Hello. It was so good, and I don't normally do that. You know, back in the day, Sean, J.B. used to have every morning when we were shooting rest of Vellment, we'd walk through rehearsal, and he'd be holding on for dear life to a breakfast.
但我敢打赌，那个培根鸡蛋起司三明治一定涂满了呃，非常美味的奶油和……嗯，不，更像是面包烤得刚刚好，所以吃起来……边缘有点嚼劲，带点酥脆，但中间非常柔软。对，起司太丝滑了。你好。太好吃了，我平时不怎么那样。你知道的，以前，肖恩，J.B. 以前每天早晨我们在拍《发展受阻》时，我们会在排练中走来走去，他会死死抓住一份早餐。
Burrito, two hands. And Mitch Hurwitz would be like, yeah, we're doing this, and you can go, and he'd be hammering at breakfast. I mean, every morning, right, Jamie? Yeah, I couldn't understand why I was holding so much water weight in my face. But I don't usually have breakfast, but today I felt like I needed it. I don't ever have breakfast yet. I fast.
早餐卷饼，两只手抓着。米奇·赫威茨会说，行，我们开始拍，你可以走了，而他会狼吞虎咽地吃早餐。我是说，每天早晨，对吧，杰米？对，我当时不明白为什么我的脸会水肿得那么厉害。但我通常不吃早餐，但今天我觉得我需要它。我从来不吃早餐的。我辟谷。
Oh, I was up early because I'm on East Coast time, so I was up super earl, and I was like, I got to eat some. And did you walk over to the Liora place? You get elected delivery? I did an Uber Eats type deal Well, how can it arrive hot and fresh If it's delivered? It's not delivery, it's de journo.
哦，我起得很早，因为我用的是美东时间，所以我起得超级早，然后我就想，我得吃点东西。你是步行去莱奥拉那家店的吗？你是叫的外卖吗？我用了类似 Uber Eats 的服务……嗯，如果是外卖，怎么能送来时又热又新鲜呢？这不是外卖，这是迪儒诺（Frozen Pizza品牌）。
Guys, have you not... Do you not know that? So stupid. I want you guys to know that I am in a puddle Of my own sweat right now. So is that sweat? I thought that way you got out of the shower. That's disgusting.
伙计们，你们没有……你们不知道那个吗？太蠢了。我想让你们知道，我现在正泡在自己的汗水里。所以那是汗？我还以为那是你刚洗完澡呢。太恶心了。
I know. I didn't time my workout Slash sauna slash shower slash get dressed. Stop slashing. get and then I slash to the podcast. Look, I got a fucking, I got a sauna sweat or workout sweat? This is still, this is post-shower even sweat.
我知道。我没有算好我的健身/桑拿/洗澡/穿衣的时间。别再用斜杠了。然后我“斜杠”到了播客这儿。听着，我他妈的，这是桑拿出的汗还是健身出的汗？这依然是，这是洗完澡之后出的汗。
No. Oh, so it is a shower. Yeah, the hair is, yeah, but the face, I mean, oh. Wow. Oh, my body. Well, thank God you took a shower. Yeah. I'm going to need another one after this.
不。哦，所以这确实是洗澡。对，头发是，是的，但是脸，我是说，哦。哇。哦，我的身体。好吧，谢天谢地你洗了个澡。是的。这之后我还需要再洗一个。
Will you shower after this? You bet. Yeah. And did you already, did you already go through your, whole process this morning? Have I emptied? Yes. Yeah.
你一会儿还要洗澡吗？当然。是的。你今天早上已经完成了你，整个流程了吗？我排空了吗？是的。是的。
Yeah, okay. Have you? Have you? Obviously, did that happen? Sean? What, have I? I haven't taken a shower yet. No, I'll take a shower right after that.
是的，好吧。你呢？你呢？显然，那发生了吗？肖恩？什么，我有吗？我还没洗澡呢。没有，我录完这个就去洗澡。
Done everything else? No, nothing. I never do. I don't even eat. What do you mean you never do? What do you got a zipper on that thing? What do you? No, I don't.
其他都做完了？没有，什么都没有。我从来不。我甚至不吃东西。什么叫你从来不？你那玩意儿上有拉链吗？你是什么？没有，我没有。
I don't eat breakfast. What do you? What do you? What do you? What's your nickname? Waste management? What's going on? No, I don't.
我不吃早餐。你是什么？你是什么？你是什么？你的昵称是什么？废物处理厂？怎么回事？没有，我没有。
I don't. I don't have to poop in the morning. You're not regular. No, not at all. We've covered this a number of times over the years. I'm sorry. Hold on. But just real quick.
我没有。我早上不需要拉屎。你排便不规律。没有，一点也不规律。这些年来我们已经讨论过好几次了。对不起。等等。但就问一下。
Is it once a day at least, though, Shoney? Well, maybe sometimes not. So I feel like that's a problem. I don't. I talked to my doctor about it. He said if you go something like four days without it. This is the one you've been seeing during your frequent visits to the emergency room? No, this is somebody else.
肖尼，至少一天一次吗？嗯，也许有时没有。所以我觉得这是个问题。我没有。我和我的医生谈过这件事。他说如果你像这样四天不排便……这就是你频繁去急诊室时看的那位医生吗？不，这是另一个人。
This is a different. You went ahead and decided to restaff your team. No, I went to the ass doctor for all that stuff. Oh, yeah. He's great. But yeah, no, he said it's normal. But anyway, should we get to our guest? I mean, is that a weird transition?
这是另一个。你擅自决定给你的团队重新安排人员了？没有，我为了所有那些事去看过屁股医生。哦，对。他很棒。但是，好吧，不，他说那是正常的。不管怎样，我们该聊聊我们的嘉宾了吗？我是说，这是一个奇怪的过渡吗？
I mean, sure. I think we're all still, our minds are all still on what's going on with you. Is this your, Sean's? This is mine's, mine. I was tipping my sandwich in, you. In ketchup, by the way, in case I'm just doing a drag. But you were dragging it too, yeah. Not even dead drag.
我是说，当然。我觉得我们大家的，我们的脑子都还在想你身上的事。这是你的吗，肖恩的？这是我的，我的。顺便说一句，我在把三明治蘸进，你。蘸进番茄酱里，以防我只是在胡乱蘸着吃。但你也在蘸，对吧。甚至不是随便蘸蘸。
I know. It was a full drag. Get him out here, Sean. All right, he grew up in Reston, Virginia. I'm thinking about dragging ketchup. That sounds so good. As a teenager, he cold-called record labels. Why you take a dump first before you think about putting more in your face?
我知道。这是狠狠地蘸了一下。让他出来吧，肖恩。好的，他在弗吉尼亚州雷斯顿长大。我在想要蘸番茄酱。听起来太棒了。十几岁时，他冷不丁地给唱片公司打电话。在你考虑往嘴里塞更多东西之前，为什么不先去拉个屎呢？
Okay? Dump truck. Waste management. We're just so worried about the backup. Go ahead, Sean. I know. I don't have it. I don't feel it. As a teenager, guys, he cold-called.
好吗？自卸卡车。废物处理厂。我们只是太担心堵车了。说吧，肖恩。我知道。我没有。我没感觉。十几岁时，伙计们，他冷不丁地给……
record labels pretending to be Jay Z's attorney. On weekends, he took the five-hour bus trip to New York to DJ parties, hauling a desktop computer from club to club because he didn't own a laptop. He couldn't afford a hotel, so he slept in train stations, parks, and the McDonald's and Times Square. Before he turned 25, he'd co-written
唱片公司打电话，假装是 Jay-Z 的律师。周末，他坐五个小时的巴士去纽约打碟开派对，把一台台式电脑从一家俱乐部拖到另一家俱乐部，因为他没有笔记本电脑。他住不起酒店，所以睡在火车站、公园和时代广场的麦当劳。在他 25 岁之前，他共同创作……
and produced Keshe's TikTok and Rihanna's Diamonds, you may have heard of his wife, Selena Gomez. It's the singular and super cool, Benny Blanco. Beni Blanco. Here we go. This guy's got answers for us. How are you doing? There is. Benny, how's your morning, Ben?
并制作了 Kesha 的《TikTok》和 Rihanna 的《Diamonds》，你可能听说过他的妻子，赛琳娜·戈麦斯。他就是独一无二且超级酷的贝尼·布兰科。贝尼·布兰科。我们开始吧。这家伙有答案要给我们。你好吗？这不就来了。贝尼，你早上过得怎么样，本？
Well. That's a soft question right there. You go ahead, take it wherever you want to go with that. First of all, I'm empty. That's a boy. Second of all. Second of all, your doctor said you can, four days. That's insane.
挺好。这是一个很温和的问题。你想把话题带到哪里就带到哪里。首先，我排空了。好样的。第二点。第二点，你的医生说你可以，四天。太疯狂了。
They need to leave their license. What are you talking about? Yeah, he said that was okay. Did you get a deal on this doctor? No, his doctor doesn't hold any actual licenses, you're saying. Yeah, my doctor. says four days too. Yeah.
他们应该被吊销执照。你在说什么？对，他说那没问题。你是在这个医生身上捡到便宜了吗？不，你是说他的医生没有任何实际执照。对，我的医生。也说四天。对。
Four days, Shawnee? Yeah, yeah, yeah, four days. That's not. All right, we'll get off a subject. Maybe I got it wrong. Wait, hi, Benny, how are you? Benny and I do know each other a little bit. We do know each other a little bit.
四天，肖尼？对，对，对，四天。这不对。好吧，我们换个话题。也许我弄错了。等等，嗨，贝尼，你好吗？贝尼和我确实认识一点。我们确实认识一点。
We do know each other a little bit. We did a commercial together. Oh, what commercial? For Duncan. Duncan Donuts. Oh, right on. Wow. That's all we got.
我们确实认识一点。我们一起拍过广告。哦，什么广告？唐恩。唐恩都乐。哦，原来如此。哇。我们就这些了。
That's all we got. How about the Tim Horton's folks? Would they be upset about that, Willie? Well, we don't know, eh? we haven't been in touch with them. That's a Canadian outfit, Benny. Oh, I know. It's a Canadian dunking.
我们就这些了。蒂姆霍顿的人怎么样？威利，他们会为此不高兴吗？嗯，我们不知道，嗯？我们一直没跟他们联系。那是家加拿大公司，贝尼。哦，我知道。那是加拿大的唐恩。
Wait, Benny, what's on the wall behind you with all the charts and the graphs? The other side. Guys, I don't. No, the other side. The other side. What office are you borrowing? Are you in a school?
等等，贝尼，你身后墙上贴着的那一堆图表和曲线图是什么？另一边。伙计们，我没有。不，另一边。另一边。你借了谁的办公室？你在学校吗？
I'm in my doctor's office right now. Hold on. It says, shitting, every four of the next days. I don't know. This is a weird doctor's office. No, it is a very strange room. Everywhere I look, there's maps.
我现在在我医生的办公室里。等等。上面写着，每四天拉一次屎。我不知道。这是一个奇怪的医生办公室。不，这是一个非常奇怪的房间。我放眼望去，到处都是地图。
We are in an Airbnb. Well, I don't even know if it's an Airbnb. I call everything in Airbnb. Sure, sure. If you're renting a house. Like, there's no other name. It's like any time. It's a cut and swab.
我们在一个爱彼迎里。好吧，我甚至不知道它是不是爱彼迎。我把一切都叫爱彼迎。当然，当然。如果你在租房子。就像没有别的名字一样。就像任何时候。这是一次剪切和棉签。
Yeah, yeah. I'm in a rental home in London. God. And I've been here for a very long time. How long have you been there? About six years. No, I've been, well, it's such a stupid story. Basically, I don't fly.
对，对。我在伦敦的一栋出租屋里。天哪。我在这里待了很长时间了。你在那儿待了多久？大约六年。不，我待了，好吧，这是一个愚蠢的故事。基本上，我不坐飞机。
By the way, can I tell you something? That's my first question. I want to get into it. Okay, well, hey, well, he's telling it. He was halfway through it. I know, Sean, I don't care. Just that you want to take it wherever you want, Sean, let's do it. You might be a little constipated.
顺便说一句，我能告诉你一件事吗？那是我的第一个问题。我想深入了解一下。好吧，嘿，好吧，他正在讲呢。他讲了一半了。我知道，肖恩，我不在乎。既然你想把话题带到任何你想去的地方，肖恩，我们开始吧。你可能有点便秘。
You might need to get out. Excuse me, he's a little backed up. Go ahead, Benny. So you don't fly. It's affecting his brain. Oh, yeah, I know. It's getting on a brain. Circulation to his brain.
你可能需要出去走走。对不起，他有点堵塞。说吧，贝尼。所以你不坐飞机。这正在影响他的脑子。哦，对，我知道。这在侵蚀脑子。脑部血液循环。
Okay. So, so basically, I stopped flying a long time ago. My neuroses took over. I've flown a handful of times in the last like 10 years. But I'm so insane that I take the boat to Europe. Wow. So I take every time I go to Europe,
好吧。所以，基本上，我很早就停止坐飞机了。我的神经官能症占了上风。在过去大约 10 年里，我只坐过几次飞机。但我疯狂到坐船去欧洲。哇。所以我每次去欧洲，
I have to drive from L.A. to New York. And then I get on a boat for seven days to Europe. But how long is the drive from L.A. to New York? I mean, it's as long as you want it. You can do it in 41 hours if you want, but you can stretch it out to two weeks. Never the train? Never the train?
我都必须从洛杉矶开车到纽约。然后我坐七天的船去欧洲。但从洛杉矶开车到纽约要多久？我是说，随你高兴多长时间。如果你愿意，可以在 41 小时内完成，但你也可以把它拖到两个星期。从来不坐火车吗？从来不坐火车吗？
I've done it. I've done every form except walking. Benny, I love this so much. Okay, so can you say, first of all, seven days on a boat, and then you get there, so of course you've been there a long time because you don't want to take the trip back. But what about the Ed Shearin's story?
我坐过。除了走路，我什么形式都试过了。贝尼，我太喜欢这个了。好吧，所以你能说说，首先，在船上待七天，然后你到了那里，所以你当然在那儿待了很久，因为你不想再坐船回去。但是埃德·希兰的故事呢？
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no. What's the boat like? Okay. The boat is the actual Titanic. Like, I'm on the Titanic. I'm on, it's not like a Yyronin'I. or something. I'm on the Cunard.
不，不，不，不，不，不，不，不。那艘船是什么样的？好吧。这艘船实际上就是泰坦尼克号。就像，我在泰坦尼克号上。我在，它不是那种小游艇什么的。我在卡纳德游轮上。
Like, yeah, I'm on like a, essentially like a carnival cruise with all British people. But it's kind of badass, right? You got a nice cabin. Yeah? Define high end. Well, like, let's say the Orient Express
就像，是的，我基本上就像是在一艘载满英国人的嘉年华游轮上。但它挺带劲的，对吧？你有一个不错的客舱。是吧？定义一下高端。嗯，比如说，东方快车，
but floating. No, no. It's like, does that exist? No, no. Oh, I think it does. Like the Titanic doesn't exist anymore, right? They're building the Titanic too, for real, from scratch, and it's going to be exactly a replica.
但它是浮动的。不，不。就像，这真的存在吗？不，不。哦，我想是的。就像泰坦尼克号已经不存在了，对吧？他们正在从头开始建造真正的泰坦尼克号 2 号，它将是一个完全的复制品。
Well, great idea. Let's keep that going. My mom's actually on a fancy, my mom's on a fancy cruise right now. So there's, so I know it exists. It just doesn't exist on my travel trajectory. So I'm sitting, yeah, basically, Sean, you want the story. Yeah.
嗯，好主意。让我们继续保持这样。我妈妈现在实际上正坐在一艘豪华游轮上。所以有，所以我知道它是存在的。它只是不存在于我的旅行轨迹中。所以我坐着，是的，基本上，肖恩，你想听故事。对。
I was, I was, I was making an album with Ed Shearer. We're making an album called Divide. It took us like two and a half years. We were on tour all over America. He said, I have to finish it at my house in my hometown where I go. grew up in England. And I said, okay, that's really cool, but I don't fly. And he said, well, what if we take a boat?
我当时，我当时，我当时正在和埃德·希兰制作一张专辑。我们在制作一张名为《Divide》的专辑。我们花了大约两年半的时间。我们在全美各地巡演。他说，我必须在我长大的家乡英国的房子里把它做完。我说，好吧，这真的很酷，但我部坐飞机。他说，如果我们坐船呢？
I said, what do you mean take a boat? We looked it up. It's the Queen Mary. He's like, yeah, I think it'll be a cool idea. So we're on the boat. In theory, it's a great idea. Like, it sounds like an amazing idea. Yeah, right.
我说，什么叫坐船？我们查了一下。那是玛丽女王号。他说，是的，我觉得这会是个好主意。所以我们在船上。理论上，这是一个极好的主意。听起来像个绝妙的主意。对吧。
It's cool for a day and a half. Right. Everything else, you're like, I usually start to go insane about four days in, and you're just like, you don't even know who you are anymore. It's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, it's, right, right. You've all four corners of this boat and all the people and you just, you're ready to jump over. They got the intranet on there. They got the internet.
前一天半还挺酷的。对吧。其余时间，你会觉得，我通常在大约第四天开始发疯，你会觉得，你甚至不知道自己是谁了。这，这，这，这，对吧，对吧。你把这艘船的四个角落和所有人都看遍了，你准备好跳下去了。他们上面有互联网。他们有互联网。
They got the internet. They got like Starlink. It's, it's, that's, that's, that's good. The first time I went, the internet was so bad, and it cost like, it costs like, it costs like a million dollars. Like, the first time I went on, you would be like this. I'd be like, like, like, just signing on, just trying to, like, figure out everything. Uh-huh. And then what?
他们有互联网。他们有类似星链的东西。这，这，这挺好的。我第一次去的时候，互联网太烂了，而且花得像，花得像，花得像一百万美元。就像，我第一次上去的时候，你会这样。我会像，像，像，只是登录，只是试图，像，弄清楚一切。嗯哼。然后呢？
about any high seas ever? Yeah, I've been on in a hurricane. God, flying is better. That scares me. Big, big, big waves. There's only been one, there's only been one, the both sunk one time out of like a million. It's the best odds.
遇到过大风浪吗？对，我遇过飓风。天哪，坐飞机更好。那可吓死我了。大，大，大浪。大约有一百万次航行中只有一次，只有一次船沉了。这是最好的几率。
And they've made a great movie out of it. Yeah, but I mean, but aren't you worried? I can't, every documentary is like about diarrhea on a cruise ship, on any ship. Yeah. How bad. Sean, you should be doing. Yeah, you need to go tomorrow. Get a ticket tomorrow.
他们还把它拍成了一部伟大的电影。对，但是我的意思是，难道你不担心吗？我不能，每个纪录片都在讲游轮上、任何船上的腹泻。对。有多糟糕。肖恩，你真该去。对，你明天就得去。明天就买张票。
Yeah. Let's get the motor running. Yeah. Prime the pump a little bit. Well, I actually make my own food on the boat. Oh, let's get about foggoy for his bathroom. Yeah, exactly. I actually make my own food on the boat.
对。让引擎转起来。对。给泵加点引水。好吧，其实我在船上自己做饭。哦，我们别聊他的洗手间了。对，没错。其实我在船上自己做饭。
What food? What do you mean? What does that mean? How do you do? I like bring it and I have like a little refrigerator. I either use like a rice cooker or an air fryer. And I just, I want to have my own food. I don't like the food on the boat.
什么食物？什么意思？那是什么意思？你怎么做？我喜欢带上食物，我有一个小冰箱。我用电饭煲或者空气炸锅。我只想吃自己的食物。我讨厌船上的食物。
Kill, what was, tell me, tell me about the inciting incident that got you out of the sky and into the water. Okay. I love the way I phrase my question. Sure. I love phrasing questions. Basically, I'm in, it's the same day. What's that guy's named Sully, who got the plane in the-
基尔，快告诉我，告诉我那个让你不再坐飞机、改走水路的诱发事件是什么。好吧。我喜欢我提问的方式。当然。我喜欢措辞考究的问题。基本上，我在，那是同一天。那家伙叫什么名字来着，把飞机开到——
Sully Sullenberger. Yeah, yeah. It's the exact same day. Sully landed the plane in the fucking river. Hudson River. So, yeah. So I'm on my way to the airport. All my friends are calling.
萨利·萨伦伯格。对，对。就在同一天。萨利把飞机降落在那该死的河里。哈德逊河。所以，是的。所以我正在去机场的路上。我所有的朋友都打来电话。
me and they're saying, are you okay? And I said, what do you mean am I okay? They said, that plane, we thought you were on that plane because I guess I was on one similar time. And I said, no. So I hear that and I'm not even afraid. I'm like, man, what a crazy coincidence. I get on a plane to Atlanta. And it got dicey. You know how I know it got dicey. I was always all good on a plane because you looked at the stewardess and they were stoked. They were stoked. I looked at the stewardess and she had a fear in her eyes. I've never seen on a plane before. So I was like...
问我你还好吗。我说我怎么会不好？他们说，那架飞机，我们以为你在那架飞机上，因为我猜我以前坐过类似的航班。我说，没有。所以我听到这个消息时甚至一点都不害怕。我想，天哪，多么疯狂的巧合。我登上了去亚特兰大的飞机。情况开始变得棘手了。你们怎么知道情况变得棘手了。我以前坐飞机总是感觉很好，因为你看空姐，她们都很兴奋。她们很兴奋。我看着空姐，从她眼中看到了我以前在飞机上从未见过的恐惧。所以我当时想……
Because the level of turbulence? There was a level of turbulence, and we weren't allowed to walk the entire flight. You couldn't stand up to go to the bathroom. I remember the one traumatic thing is this lady is trying to get the cart down, and the cart goes flying, and she goes flying too. And the medic gets one of the ladies, the stewardess. So it's just an awful flight where you think you're going to, everyone's had that one.
因为湍流的程度？有一定程度的湍流，而且整个航程中我们都不准走动。你不能站起来去上厕所。我记得有一件创伤性的事情是，一位女士试图推着餐车过去，然后餐车飞了出去，她也飞了出去。医疗人员去照顾其中一位女士，也就是空姐。所以这是一次糟糕透顶的航班，你会觉得自己快要，每个人都经历过那种航班。
But I got off and then I had like slightly a bad flight like a few weeks later. And I was just like, you know what? Maybe I'll drive to New York the next time. That was like, and then it just kind of started like that. And it's just like a neuroses that grew. And I wish I could say. And you fall in love with long drives too. I love driving long distances.
但我下了飞机，几周后又经历了一次稍微有点糟糕的航班。我当时就想，你知道吗？也许下次我该开车去纽约。大概就是这样开始的。这只是一种不断滋生的神经官能症。我真希望我能说。你也爱上了长途驾驶，对吧？我喜欢开长途车。
And, you know, I bet that. boat is super relaxing for you, you know? I mean, like, it truly, I mean, it gives you, like, focus time to just, like, do what you want to do and, like, get bored and, you know, a lot of relaxation happens in boredom, I find. Yeah. Well, and creativity. Yeah.
而且，我敢打赌，那艘船对你来说超级放松，你知道吗？我是说，真的，我是说，它给了你，比如，专注的时间来做你想做的事，比如，感到无聊，而且，你知道，我发现很多放松都发生在无聊之中。是的。嗯，还有创造力。是的。
Which is a great segue, Will. Well, thank you. Well, no, I was just going to say, I mean, people talk about it. It's not an original idea, but you talk, you see people talk about these days about how we used to, prior to social media and smartphones and stuff, I mean, you remember as you were a kid, how many hours spent staring out the window as you were driving? Oh, my God. Yeah.
这是一个很好的过渡，威尔。谢谢。好吧，不，我只是想说，人们经常谈论这个。这不是一个原创新主意，但你谈到，你看到人们如今在讨论，在我们有社交媒体、智能手机等东西之前，我是说，你还记得当你还是个孩子的时候，开车时盯着窗外看了多少个小时吗？哦，天哪。是的。
All you did was on a plane, in the car with your folks, whatever, just staring out the window. Or Sean, like, staring out the living room window, wondering, like, is he coming back? Is he going to come back? Is he ever coming back? Guys, I was talking about this. I was talking about this the other day with my friend.
你唯一做的事就是在飞机上、在跟你爸妈的车里，随便什么车里，就是盯着窗外看。或者像肖恩一样，盯着客厅的窗户看，心里纳闷，他会回来吗？他会回来吗？他还会回来吗？伙计们，我正在谈论这个。我前几天还在和我的朋友谈论这个。
Back in the day, you'd say, hey, meet me to play basketball after school. So you'd go, you'd say, meet me. You'd go there, your friend wouldn't be there. You'd get home after dark. You couldn't call them because it was too late to call someone's house. So you had to wait till the next day to say, hey, man, where were you? And like any excuse they said was valid.
过去，你会说，嘿，放学后在篮球场见。所以你会去，你会说，在那见。你去了，你的朋友不在那。天黑后你回到家。你不能打电话，因为太晚了，不能给别人家里打电话。所以你不得不等到第二天说，嘿，兄弟，你昨天去哪了？而且无论他们编什么借口都是合理的。
People used to not be accessible. Now if you don't answer a text, they FaceTime you, then they Facebook you, then they Instagram. You know, it's too much. Yeah. I want to go backwards. Yeah. Yeah, let's go backwards. But speaking about creativity.
过去人们没那么容易联系到。现在如果你不回短信，他们会给你发 FaceTime，然后给你发 Facebook 消息，然后给你发 Instagram。你知道，这太过了。是的。我想回到过去。是的。是的，让我们回到过去。不过说到创造力。
When flying was luxurious. Yeah. I remember you used to show us up. Sean, get back to the plan. Sorry, you got a plan ahead of you. Yeah, talk me. Get back to the grid. What's your plan, Sean?
当飞行还很奢侈的时候。是的。我记得你以前总是出风头。肖恩，回到计划上来。对不起，你面前有个计划。对，跟我说。回到正轨上来。肖恩，你的计划是什么？
What's on the grid, Sean? No, well, I mean, I just want, first of all, I've never met you, and I'm, like, enamored with you. And all your success. Same. For people don't, my sister might not know. Maybe, maybe she does. What's your sister's name? My sister's name is Tracy.
网格上有什么，肖恩？不，好吧，我是说，我只是想，首先，我从来没见过你，而且我，就像，迷恋上你了。还有你所有的成就。我也是。对于那些不知道的人，我姐姐可能不知道。也许，也许她知道。你姐姐叫什么名字？我姐姐叫特雷西。
Hey, Tracy. Hey, Tracy. Yes. But all, I mean, do you ever, do you ever just stop and think about all the success you've had and you're still so young. You've written massive hit songs for Justin Bieber, Ed Shearren, Katie Perry, Maroon 5. I mean, I'm reading these.
嘿，特雷西。嘿，特雷西。是的。但是所有，我是说，你有没有，你有没有停下来想过你所取得的所有成就，而你现在还这么年轻。你为贾斯汀·比伯、埃德·希兰、凯蒂·佩里、魔力红写过巨大的热门歌曲。我是说，我正在读这些。
Kesha, Brittany Spears, Snoop Dog, Halsey, I mean, Kanye West. I mean, everybody in the music business has a song by you, which is just mind-blowing. And so when I was doing my research on you and learning, like, wow, and this all started when your brother took you to a record store. Is that how it started?
Kesha、布兰妮·斯皮尔斯、史努比·道格、霍尔希，还有坎耶·韦斯特。我是说，音乐界每个人都有一首你写的歌，这简直令人大开眼界。所以当我做关于你的研究并了解到，哇，这一切都是从你哥哥带你去唱片店开始的。是这样开始的吗？
Essentially. Essentially. That's true. That's true. Okay. And what happened? and like what are some of the first albums you got and like why did that? I was, I was, I got very into music when I was like four or five. I was super into it. And my brother, this was like the era of the CD book
基本上是这样。基本上是这样。是真的。是真的。好的。然后发生了什么？比如你买的第一张专辑是什么，为什么会那样？我，我，我在四五岁的时候就非常迷恋音乐。我超级迷恋。我哥哥，这还是 CD 盒的年代，
and the tape, like, you remember you used to have the book and you could flip through and it was like the most coveted item in the house. Yeah. Yeah. And I was blown away. It was actually a little before that. I was cassettes.
还有磁带，就像，你还记得你曾经有那种可以翻页的书，那是家里最让人垂涎的物品。对。是的。我惊呆了。其实在那之前一点点。那是磁带时代，
and then the CD book came out like maybe probably when I was like eight or nine. When you say the CD book, you're talking about the storage. Why I got all the envelopes? I still have mine. I still have mine. Yeah, yeah. So, yeah, tapes first came out. Case logic, I think was a big one.
然后 CD 盒出来了，大概在我八九岁的时候吧。你说的 CD 盒，是指收纳包吗？为什么我所有的信封都在里面？我还有我的。我还留着我的。对，对。所以，是的，磁带先出来的。Case Logic，我觉得是个大牌子。
Yeah, I went to store. Here we go. Here's a gifting from Case Logic on its way. No, I think they're resting right now. First tape I ever bought was by Nas. It was called The World is Yours. And then the second tape I ever bought was all for one. Yeah, yeah, the icewear by the moon. Yeah.
对，我去商店了。我们走吧。来自 Case Logic 的礼物正在路上。不，我觉得他们现在正歇着呢。我买的第一盒磁带是 Nas 的。专辑名叫《The World is Yours》。然后我买的第二盒磁带是 All-4-One 的。对，对，那个《I Swear》的。对。
And so I was buying this shit and my mom was like had such a good taste of music. You know, my mom was like really a music head. So we were like, I was listening to like Prince and like Teddy Pendergrass at home. And like I had like I had, so I had the ying and the yang. and I actually wasn't even like a huge pop music fan until I started making it. Like I really didn't even, I really didn't even, I didn't really know it much.
所以我买这些破玩意儿，我妈妈的音乐品味真好。你知道，我妈妈真的是个音乐迷。所以我们在家里，我听着像 Prince 和 Teddy Pendergrass 的歌。而且我有，我有，所以我既有阴又有阳。而且我其实甚至都不是一个超级流行音乐迷，直到我开始创作流行音乐。我是说我真的甚至都不，我真的甚至都不，我其实对它了解不多。
Wow. Right, right, right, right. Was, like, when you were doing all that, my friends were really into like classic rock. And so it was all about like Zeppelin and stones and doors and all that stuff. Was there ever a big rock and roll draw for you? Yeah, first. So when I'm a big, about seven is when like the whole grunge scene hit.
哇。对，对，对，对。当你在做所有这些事的时候，我的朋友们真的很喜欢经典摇滚。所以一切都是关于齐柏林飞艇、滚石、门乐队以及所有这些东西。摇滚乐对你来说从来没有过巨大的吸引力吗？有，首先。所以当我大约七岁的时候，整个垃圾摇滚（Grunge）浪潮爆发了。
So I'm going crazy with my brother. I'm losing my mind. And then my dad was a huge, you know, there was a big war in my house. My mom, my mom was Beatles and my dad was stones. So it was like a big war when I was first growing up. So they were big, yeah, like my mom, like grew up like going to like CBGBs in Studio 54. Like she was like very in that world.
所以我跟我哥一起疯狂。我快要疯了。然后我我爸是个超级，你知道，我家曾有过一场大战。我妈，我妈喜欢披头士，我爸喜欢滚石。所以当我刚长大的时候，那就像是一场大战。所以他们很大，是的，就像我妈，就像是在 CBGB 和 54 工作室长大的。就像她非常融入那个世界。
So yeah, I was, you know, we had a record player. I was very, I was like an old soul before I got into pop music. So I think it like helped me. And so music was a big part of your family life. Like everybody, this was a thing that everybody listened to a lot of music. Yeah, no one did like, like nobody had, nobody played music. Nobody did anything. No, but they appreciated it.
所以，是的，你知道，我们有一台唱片机。在我接触流行音乐之前，我就是一个老派灵魂。所以我认为这对我有所帮助。所以音乐是你家庭生活中的很大一部分。就像每个人，这是每个人都听很多音乐的事。是的，没有人做过，就像，没有人演奏音乐。没有人做任何事。不，但他们欣赏它。
Yeah, they appreciated music. Everyone appreciated music. And even though like, my. My mom was like, shut the fuck up, stop banging everything, like, all over the house. Like, like, I was, I was so annoying. Did you have, but my mom used to make us turn the music down in the car. She always hated music in the car. Yeah, to this day.
是的，他们欣赏音乐。每个人都欣赏音乐。尽管，我的。我妈妈会说，闭上你妈的嘴，别在家里到处敲敲打打了，就像，就像，我太烦人了。你有没有，但我妈妈以前让我们把车里的音乐声音调小。她总是讨厌车里的音乐。对，直到今天。
She'd be like, turn it. She can't take the noise. My mom was oblivious to people who were like, like, remember Culture Club, boy George? She'd be like, he has such a beautiful voice. Like, she wouldn't know he was the big gay guy. She's pretty oblivious to everyone on her right side. Right. My mom, my mom, one time I took my mom.
她会说，关小点。她受不了噪音。我妈妈对那些人一无所知，比如，比如，还记得文化俱乐部（Culture Club）的乔治男孩吗？她会说，他的声音太美了。就像，她根本不知道他是个大同性恋。她对她右边的每个人都一无所知。对。我妈妈，我妈妈有一次我带我妈妈去。
It's a nice way of saying she had a few blind spots. Yeah, exactly. My mom had one eye, Benny. Okay, go ahead. Oh, your mother had one eye? Yeah, it's a long eye. She had two, just one of them was glass. Which we brought up.
这是委婉地说法，说明她有一些盲点。是的，正好。我妈妈有一只眼睛，贝尼。好吧，继续。哦，你母亲有一只眼睛？对，这是一个长期的眼疾。她有两只，只是其中一只事玻璃的。我们刚刚提到了。
It was glass. It wasn't glass. Oh, I don't know, it was glass. It was glass. It was glass. One eye. Wait, what were we going to say, Benny? Sorry.
是玻璃的。不是玻璃的。哦，我不知道，那是玻璃的。那是玻璃的。那是玻璃的。一只眼睛。等等，我们要说什么来着，贝尼？抱歉。
So my mother, I took her to a Maroon 5 show, okay? and I've been doing music for them. And we're backstage, and she literally walked up to Adam Levine and she said, hey, do you mind like turning down the base a little when you guys perform? No, really? No. My mom is, she's so fucking oblivious.
所以我的母亲，我带她去看了一场魔力红的演唱会，好吧？我一直在为他们做音乐。我们在后台，她径直走向亚当·莱文，对他说，嘿，你们表演的时候介意把低音调小一点吗？真的假的？没有。我妈妈，她太他妈无知了。
And I said, Mom, he's not going to turn down the base? She said, why? Why is it such a big deal? It's so loud. Yeah. She told them to turn down the base. My mother also, like, when someone's coming, like, let's say, like, Let's say like Britney Spears was going to, like, do Jimmy Fallon or something.
我说，妈，他才不会把低音调小呢！她说，为什么？这有什么大不了的？声音太大了。是的。她让他们把低音调小。我母亲还，比如当有人要来，比如，比方说，比方说布兰妮·斯皮尔斯要去上吉米·法伦的节目之类的。
She'd be like, oh, I saw Britney Spears in a time. You know, she could stay at my house if she wants to. She's not staying at your house. She's like, well, you know her. Why does she just, like, she's staying at, what are you talking about? Like, my mom lives in, like, some alternate reality. Yeah, what about your dad? What did your dad do growing up?
她会说，哦，我以前在某个地方见过布兰妮·斯皮尔斯。你知道的，如果她愿意，她可以住在我家。她才不suites住你家呢。她说，好吧，你认识她。为什么她不，就像，她住在，你在说什么？就像，我妈妈生活在某种平行现实中。对，你爸爸呢？你爸爸在你长大时是做什么的？
Both my parents had, like, so, my parents divorced when I was. when I was pretty young. But like, so my mom, my dad was in the intimate apparel business. He like made like old lady nightgowns. Hell yeah. Oh, really. Like, he made, yeah, yeah, very sexy. He made like old lady nightgowns.
我父母都有，所以，我父母在我很小的时候就离婚了。但是，所以我的我妈妈，我爸爸从事的是贴身内衣生意。他制作老太太的睡裙。太棒了。哦，真的吗。就像，他制作，非常性感。他制作老太太的睡裙。
Like literally like the ones who like see in Target. Yeah, it's like super. Oh. Oh, yeah. Well, he said like you're really choking one off there. Oh, yeah. He's like, oh. And then my mother's job was like,
就像你在塔吉特百货（Target）看到的那些。对，超级。哦。哦，是的，好吧，他说你那是在掐死自己呢。哦，是的。他说，哦。然后我妈妈的工作是，
Couldn't be, it's like even worse. My mom, like, do you know, like, do you know J.C. Penny's? Of course. And like Macy's. My mother would fix the jewelry display boxes when you went to J.C. Petty. Oh, okay, okay. And then her, like, big break was that she worked, like, she quit that and, like, finally got a good job at, like, an old folks home. And she worked there for, like, 15 years.
不可能，甚至更糟。我妈妈，你知道吗，你知道杰西潘尼百货（J.C. Penney）吗？当然。还有梅西百货。当你去杰西潘尼百货时，我妈妈会去整理珠宝展示柜。哦，好吧，好吧。然后她的重大突破是她去工作，她辞职了，最后在一家养老院找到了一份不错的工作。她在那里工作了大约 15 年。
Oh, wow. That is Angel Worth. That is a good way to also help your dad move some product with the other. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. Intimate apparel for older people. Now opening that demo is now availed. Honestly, if they didn't hate each other, then. Yeah, if they didn't hate each other, then it probably would have been like a billion-dollar franchise.
哦，哇。那是天使般的工作。这也是一个好方法，可以帮你的爸爸顺便向其他人推销一些产品。对，对，对，对。老年人的贴身内衣。现在开发这个细分市场现在已经行不通了。老实说，如果他们当时没有恨对方的话。是的，如果他们当时没有恨对方，那可能就会成为一个价值十亿美元的特许经营权。
Exactly. Right. And we will be right back. And now back to the show. So there's tons of kids out there right now, probably not. listening to this, but might know someone who is, that's really, they're really into music and they would love to be like a big time, you know, record producer like you. They want to be you. How would they, how do you do that? How do you, I mean, what, tell, what, how do you, I had that
没错。我们马上回来。欢迎回到节目中。所以现在外面有成千上万的孩子，可能没有在听这个，但可能会认识正在听这个的人，他们真的很喜欢音乐，他们很想成为像你这样的大牌唱片制作人。他们想成为你。他们会怎么做，你怎么做那件事？怎么做，我是说，告诉我，你怎么——我有过
same question. Well, Sean said that you just went, you, you, you, you sort of fudged your way, you went to New York and kind of, like, just pure hustle. Yeah, it was so different. Back in the day, I literally, there was no anything. So I would wait outside, like, studios and I'd be like, hey, do you make music? Like, as a person was walking by, like, you didn't know anything. There was no, there was no point of reference. And when I was younger, when I was in high school,
同样的问题。好吧，肖恩说你只是，你，你，你有点连蒙带骗，你去了纽约，靠纯粹的拼搏。是的，太不同了。过去，我简直，什么都没有。所以我会在录音室外面等待，我会说，嘿，你做音乐吗？就像对路过的人说的那样，就像你什么都不知道。没有任何参考点。当我更年轻的时候，当我还在读高中时，
MySpace first came out. Yeah, sure. So that was like, that was, like, YouTube didn't exist yet. Like, MySpace first came out. And that was how I started making my, like, first connections. And, like, what did that look like? Would you, like, listen to somebody's song and then, like, you'd email them on this new thing called email?
MySpace 刚刚问世。对，当然。所以那是，就像，YouTube 还没有诞生。就像 MySpace 刚问世一样。那是我是如何建立我最初的人脉的。这看起来是怎样的？你会，比如，听听某人的歌，然后，比如，通过这个叫做电子邮件的新东西给他们发邮件？
Yeah, this was before the music. The music portion was even, the music portion became, you used to be able to listen to people's songs like maybe four years later, three, four years later. But when I first started, yeah, I would just like email, I mean, we're all doing the same shit. I'm like doing every, I'm like, I made a song with so-and-so's brother's nephew's cousin. And then like you're slowly inching towards it. And everything you do is just like one like baby step, like just like pushing towards in an inevitable snowball that begins to have. So you would make like little songs, then you'd push them out through your MySpace page
对，这甚至是在音乐部分之前。音乐部分甚至还没有，音乐部分变得……你以前得在大约四年后、三四年后才能听到别人的歌。但当我刚开始的时候，是的，我只会发邮件，我是说我们都在做同样的破事。我像是做了一，我跟某个人的哥哥的侄子的表弟做了一首歌。然后你就在慢慢向它靠近。你做的每一件事都像是一小步，就像是推着一个不可避免的雪球开始滚动。所以你会做一些小歌，然后通过你的 MySpace 主页把它们推给
to other people and say, hey, check this out, I kind of know what I'm doing. Yeah. Kind of, I got big locally. Like, I started getting on the radio when I was young. And I like... How did that happen? How'd you get on the radio?
其他人，并说，嘿，来看看这个，我大概知道我在做什么。对。差不多，我在当地变得很有名。我年轻的时候就开始上广播节目了。我——那是怎么发生的？你是怎么上广播节目的？
I won a contest when I was like 9 or 10, and I got to go into a studio. Wow. And I used to like rap, and I got to go into a studio. Yeah. And my guitar teacher, like, made a demo tape with me. and it would just like, and then randomly my brother was in a fraternity with a guy who had a studio. And then, like, I started making music there.
我 9 岁或 10 岁时赢得了一场比赛，我得以进入一个录音室。哇。我以前喜欢说唱，我得以进入一个录音室。是的。我的吉他老师和我一起制作了一个小样磁带。然后就像，接着我哥哥偶然和一个拥有录音室的家伙在一个兄弟会里。然后，像，我开始在那里制作音乐。
And it was just like all these things that were such a pipe dream. Like, even when I was, like, successful, my parents, like, didn't believe me because it was so much of this, like, it was like, and I don't know about you guys, but my parents picked the most arbitrary things to realize that I've made it. Like, I had, like, number one songs. I had, like, multiple number one songs. And I remember I was in the New York Times, like, four years later. And my mom was like, I can't believe it. You made it. And I'm like, Mom, I was, like, already nominated for Grammy.
这一切就像是一个白日梦。就像，甚至在我成功的时候，我的父母，像，也不相信我，因为这太像，就像，我不知道你们怎么样，但我的父母挑了最随意的那些事情来意识到我已经成功了。比如，我有，像，冠军单曲。我有，像，多首冠军单曲。我记得我四年后上了《纽约时报》。我妈妈说，我简直不敢相信。你成功了。我说，妈，我，就像，都已经获得格莱美提名了。
She was like, yeah, but it's the New York Times. Yeah, yeah, yeah. You know, and it's like, yeah. And I remember I was on ESN. The first time I was on SNL, it was as, like, a backup musician. And my dad was like, I can't believe you made it. Like, and I wasn't even like, I, I, wasn't even like the main act.
她说，对，但这是《纽约时报》。对，对，对。你知道，就像是。而且我记得我上了 SNL。我第一次上 SNL 是作为，像，一个伴奏音乐人。我爸爸说，我简直不敢相信你成功了。就像，我甚至不是，我，我，甚至都不是主要表演者。
I was nothing. I had no words. I was wearing a helmet. I wasn't even, you didn't even see me. Right. A helmet in the back. Yeah, I literally had a helmet on. So you're saying there were like little tiny little baby bites that everything just kept leading to the next, leading to the next. There must have been.
我什么都不是。我没有台词。我戴着头盔。我甚至不是，你甚至看不到我。对。戴着头盔在后面。对，我literally戴着头盔。所以你是说，有那些小小的小成果，然后一切都在不断通往下一个，通往下一个。一定是的。
Yeah. Yeah. And I was. I was. I was. I mean, like, there must have been one. Yeah, there were things. Here, I'll give you like the big ticket hits real quick in like, in like a minute. Okay. We're not pressed for time, by the way, unless you are. No, no, no, no. But I'm saying, like, I've told this shit so many times. I haven't heard it.
是的。而且我。我。我是说，一定有一个。是的，有些事情。来，我马上把那些重磅热门歌曲快速讲一下，大概在一分钟内。好的。顺便说一句，我们时间不紧，除非你紧。不，不，不，不。但我是说，这破事我都讲过好多次了。我还没听过呢。
I know, but we're dumb-dums, and we haven't heard it. It's new to us, Benny, we want to know. It's just us, Benny. Here it's just us. Hey, Bee-B. Just sit down. Who calls you BB? My wife, sometimes.
我知道，但我们是笨蛋，我们没听过。这对我们来说是新鲜事，贝尼，我们想知道。这里只有我们，贝尼。这里只有我们。嘿，BB。坐下。谁叫你 BB？我妻子，有时。
But only when we write. Only in text messages. She always says, BB. And I don't know if she's saying, I've never asked her. I don't know if she's saying, like, baby. or like Benny Blanco or like beat, I don't know. Or baby, yeah. Are you listening?
但只限于我们发信息的时候。只有在短信里。她总是说，BB。我不知道她是不是在说，我从没问过她。我不知道她是在说，比如，宝贝（baby）。还是像贝尼·布兰科（Benny Blanco）或者说节拍（beat），我不知道。或者宝贝，是的。你在听吗？
Well, in the future, you'll be listening to this. What do you mean? What do you mean? She's also like, I know. I think she's in the other room, but I'm all hooked up. I can't even walk in there. Oh, you're right, yeah. So, okay, so here's what happened.
嗯，将来你会听到这个。什么意思？什么意思？她也好像，我知道。我想她在另一个房间里，但我浑身连着线。我都走不到那边去。哦，你说得对，是的。所以，好吧，事情是这样的。
Right. I got into music at a very young age. I start making songs. With boom boxes. Yeah, just like anywhere I could. I didn't have like, I didn't, I didn't, I wasn't like a bigillionaire when I was younger, so like we didn't
对。我很小的时候就接触音乐了。我开始做歌。用收音机。对，就随便在任何我能找到地方。我没有像，我没有，我没有，我年轻的时候可不是亿万富翁，所以我们并没有
really have, it was kind of just making it with whatever I had. Like I had one of those Sony Walkman like Boombox, the yellow one. Remember the yellow one? It was like this big and you could carry it on the beach. It was like kind of waterproof, yeah. Yes, I had like one of those. Sport.
真的拥有，基本上就是用我手头仅有的东西来创作。比如我有一个那种索尼随身听收音机，黄色的那个。还记得那个黄色的吗？有这么大，你可以把它带到海滩上。它有点防水，对吧？是的，我有一个那样的。运动版。
Yes, and I had like, like a Maxwell one or whatever it is. My brother had one. And we had like two. And I used to like record into one. And then I would like press play, then I would record into the other one, then I would record it. And I would make like an eight track eventually.
是的，我有一个麦克风还是什么的。我哥哥有一个。我们有两个。我以前用一个录音。然后我会按播放，然后录到另一个里，然后再录。最后我就会做出一个八轨录音。
But I didn't know I was doing that. It just because there was no, there was no YouTube. There was no ways to figure it out. So it was all like trial and error. And I started learning how to do stuff like that. And then really when I was 13, there was a guy named Sam Trocky, who was my brothers,
但我当时不知道我在这么做。只是因为当时没有，没有YouTube。当时没有什么办法能搞懂。所以这完全就像是摸着石头过河。然后我开始学习怎么做那种东西。然后到了我13岁的时候，有个叫萨姆·特罗基（Sam Trocky）的家伙，他是我哥哥的，
and my brother's fraternity. He had done like a few things. He knew a few people, record labels, and he started recording my demos in a real studio. And I was like in a real actual studio. So I started learning. What state are you in?
我哥哥的兄弟会里的。他做过一些事情。他认识一些人，包括唱片公司的人，他开始在一个真正的录音室里帮我录制小样。而我当时就像是在一个真正的、真正的录音室里。所以我开始学习。你在哪个州？
I used to travel to like Atlantic City and like Jersey. And I'm in Virginia at the time. So it's like I'm going any way I can. Friends, my brother, my mother, my father, whoever will get me, away there. You know, there's buses I would take. So I'm, you know, and I just need to use equipment because I don't have equipment's expensive.
我过去经常去大西洋城和新泽西那样的地方。我当时住在弗吉尼亚。所以这就好像是我能想尽一切办法去那里。朋友、我哥哥、我妈妈、我爸爸，谁能带我去，我就去哪。你知道的，我会坐公交车。所以，你知道的，我只是需要使用设备，因为我没有设备，设备很贵。
And I had no, like, there's not, like, I'm not asking my parents for, like, a thousand dollar thing. Right. It just, like, it wasn't an option. Right. So, so I'm, like, making demos everywhere I go. And people are starting to notice that I have something going on. There's something that's, like, a little better. than like the guys that are next to me.
而且我也没有，比如，我不可能会向父母要一千块钱的东西。对。这就好像，这不是一个选项。对。所以，所以我就像，我在去到的每个地方都做小样。人们开始注意到我有些动静了。有些东西，就像，稍微好一点。比我身边的那些家伙稍微好一点。
I still sucked. I still was terrible. Can I just pause and just say, first of all, is just a point of order? Is Benny Blanco your real name? You're given a... Benny Levin. How did you go from Benny Levin?
我当时还是很菜。我还是很糟糕。我能暂停一下，先说个程序问题吗？本尼·布兰科（Benny Blanco）是你的真名吗？你给的是一个……本尼·莱文（Benny Levin）。你是怎么从本尼·莱文变成……
When did you become Benny Blanco? I was 13. See, it's a great name. Carlito. So if I hear a kid who's got some stuff and I'm like, what's his name, Benny Blanco? I'm like, that's something.
你是什么时候变成本尼·布兰科的？我13岁的时候。看，这是个好名字。卡利托（Carlito）。所以如果我听到一个小孩有点东西，我会想，他叫什么名字？本尼·布兰科？我在想，这名字有分量。
Yeah, but in the middle of you were Benny Bounce. I was so many different things. Like, it's like, yeah, by the time I'm 13, I'm Benny Blanco from Carlito's Way. And I... Wait, was that a character's name? In Carlito's... Yeah, his character is John Liguizamo
是啊，但在那之前你叫过本尼·邦斯（Benny Bounce）。我用过好多不同的名字。就像是，没错，到我13岁的时候，我就是《情枭的黎明》（Carlito's Way）里的本尼·布兰科了。我……等等，那是角色的名字吗？在《情枭的黎明》里……对，他的角色是约翰·雷吉扎莫（John Leguizamo）
in Carlito's Way. Oh, no way. And it's so funny, when I first met him in real life, he was just like, dude, what the fuck? He's like, my whole... He's like, for so long, people have been telling me about you because it was like, I met him like maybe 10 years into my career. Yeah.
在《情枭的黎明》里。哦，不会吧。这太搞笑了，当我第一次在现实中见到他时，他就像是，老兄，搞什么鬼？他说，我的整个……他说，好长一段时间里，人们一直在向他提起我，因为我遇到他时，大约已经是我职业生涯的第十年了。是啊。
So now you're Benny Blanco, and you're making news, and people are starting to kind of notice. You're traveling, Jersey's... I'm traveling, I'm in Philly. I start getting on, like, mixtapes, okay? So, like, I would be on, like...
所以现在你是本尼·布兰科了，你开始崭露头角，人们也开始注意到你了。你在四处奔波，新泽西……我在四处奔波，我在费城。我开始登上那种，混音带，好吧？所以，就像，我会出现在……
I would be, like, back in the day, you would go to New York and you'd buy these mixtapes, and it would be, like, the diplomats. It would be, like, 50 cents. All these people would do them before they got big, and after they got big.
我会，就像，在过去，你会去纽约买这些混音带，上面会有，比如，外交官组合（The Diplomats）。会有，比如，50美分（50 Cent）。所有这些人都会在他们成名之前和成名之后做这些。
And I'm starting to get on, like, the, like, lowest-level guys, like, mix-tapes. Like, it's, like, I'm, like, I'm, like, 50s' cousins' business. brother's nephew. I'm on like his thing and I'm like, no, there's, I'm showing my friends at home. I'm like, there's like a picture of like him with 50 cent one time. And then. So wait, so these mixtapes, these were things that basically, for lack of a better term, these musical influencers would like pick these hits that they like. They'd say, hey, these are my
而我开始出现在，比如，最底层的那些家伙的混音带上。比如，这就好像，我是50美的表弟的生意人的兄弟的侄子。我出现在他的那个东西上，然后我就想，不，我有，我给家里的朋友看。我当时想，上面有我和50美分的一张照片。然后。等等，所以这些混音带，基本上就是——借用一个更好的词——这些音乐风向标会挑选他们喜欢的这些热门歌曲？他们会说，嘿，这些是我的
20 favorite songs. They put it on a cassette and they'd send it out to a bunch of people that they like. No, no. So a mixtape would be like this. In between like a rapper's big album. Okay, they would make a set of songs that, like, would just come out for free because, like, A, they couldn't get, like, samples cleared. Or, like, there was, like, artists on them. It was, like, it was illegal, making illegal music, usually, like, before an album's coming out to lead up to it, or to get yourself a record. And they're not sold in stores.
20首最喜欢的歌。他们把它们刻录在磁带上，然后寄给一堆他们喜欢的人？不，不。所以混音带是这样的。在一个说唱歌手的大专辑之间。好吧，他们会制作一组歌曲，比如，这些歌曲会免费发布，因为，A，他们无法清除采样版权。或者，比如，上面有歌手。这就好像，这是非法的，制作非法音乐，通常在专辑发行前用来铺垫，或者为自己争取一份唱片合约。而且这些不在商店里出售。
And they're not sold in the scene. Yeah, they're passed around and sold in the city. And they're done on burned cassettes or burn CDs. So they're not. Like on, like, Canal Street? Yeah. Yes, yes, exactly, exactly. And it's not such a thing anymore.
而且它们不在实体店出售。是的，它们在城里流传和出售。它们是用刻录磁带或刻录CD制作的。所以它们不是。就像在，比如，运河街（Canal Street）上？对。是的，是的，没错，没错。现在已经没这种东西了。
I'm acting like I know. Yeah, and that was also how you used to get, like, before streaming. Like, if there was, like, a hot single, that's, like, how you would go get it. Like, I would take a trip. My brother was in college, and he would near there. And, okay, so, okay, so back to the thing. So I'm doing this stuff, and I start making some noise. And it starts stretching a little bit beyond, because now I have, like, songs, and I'm
我表现得好像我懂一样。对，这也是你以前获取音乐的方式，在流媒体出现之前。比如，如果有热门单曲，你就会去买。比如，我会去旅行。我哥哥上大学时，他就住在附近。然后，好吧，所以，好吧，回到正题。所以我在做这些事，我开始搞出一些动静。它开始扩散得稍微远一点，因为现在我有，比如，歌曲，而且我在
I'm doing songs with other people. I'm still rapping, okay? I'm a rapper. And I get introduced to a man named Jonathan Schechter, okay? And he owns at the time a thing called The Source Magazine. And it was the biggest rap magazine on planet Earth. This is like New York Times for rap. And he also, at that time, had just put out a rapper's, like album before they,
我在和别人合作歌曲。我还在说唱，好吧？我是个说唱歌手。我被介绍认识了一个叫乔纳森·谢克特（Jonathan Schechter）的人，好吧？他当时拥有一家叫做《The Source》杂志的公司。它是地球上最大的说唱杂志。这就像是说唱界的《纽约时报》。而且他当时也刚刚推出过一个说唱歌手的专辑，在他们推出任何大火的作品之前，
put out any big stuff and that rapper was Eminem. And he had just, and he had also put out some stuff and he was very involved with like 50 cents early, like just like all these little things. And he was like, he was the closest
那个说唱歌手就是阿姆（Eminem）。而且他刚刚，他还推出过一些作品，他非常深入地参与了50美分早期的很多事情，就像所有这些小事情一样。而且他就像，他是我所能接触到的最大牌的圈内人。而且他以极大的方式影响着说唱音乐。所以通过这些，我开始获得更多的人脉，最终我拿到了一份唱片，我在15岁左右拿到了两份唱片合约报价。
thing I got to like as big as it gets. And he was influencing rap music in a big way. And so through that I started getting more connections and eventually I got a record, I got two record deal offers when I was about 15.
他们飞了过来，他们飞到弗吉尼亚，看我在我的高中返校节上表演。不会吧。是的。是的。这就像是，我甚至不知道，我猜当时我周围有一点点热度，而且我很年轻。这正好是小鲍沃（Lil Bow Wow）和小罗密欧（Lil Romeo）走红的时期。
And they flew down, they flew down to Virginia, and they watched me perform at my high school homecoming. No way. Yes. Yes. And it was like, I don't even, I guess there was just like a little bit of hype around me and I was young. And this was right around the time of like Lil Bow Wow and Lil Romeo.
谢克特算是认可了你。谢克特认可了我。小本尼。是的，萨姆，认可，是的，没错。人们在认可我，我拿到了一份报价。不知怎么的，我猜那个报价太差了。我当时太年轻了，几乎记不清了。我父母不让我签。
And Schechter kind of validated you. Schecter validated me. Little Benny. Yeah, Sam, validate, yeah, exactly. People were validating me, and I got an offer. Somehow, I guess the offer was so bad. I was so young, I barely remember. My parents didn't let me do it.
而那是可能发生在我身上最好的事。所以他们是你的法律顾问。他们审阅了这份报价。对，我猜当时是的。我记不清了。但在那之前，我读到你靠音乐赚到的第一笔钱是为一部软色情系列片赚的，你当时大概14、15岁。那是真的。乔纳森·谢克特拥有一家叫做“嘻哈甜心”（Hip Hop Honeys）的公司，
And it was the best thing that could have ever happened. So they were your legal counsel. They looked over the offer. Yeah, I guess so at that time. I can't remember. But before that, I read that the first money you ever made in music was for a softcore porn series, and you were like 14, 15. That is true. Jonathan Schechter owned a thing called Hip Hop Honeys,
基本上就是他们把音乐录影带里的所有女孩都找来。从音乐录影带里选出来，然后她们会赤裸跳舞，他们需要背景音乐来配合。所以他为了两首beat付了我500美元，对我来说就像在家里成了布拉德·皮特（Brad Pitt）。就像我回到家，向每个朋友展示，我有500美元，当时没人有500美元。我有500美元。
which was basically where they took all the girls for. from the music videos, and then they would dance naked, and they needed beats behind it. So he paid me $500 for two beats, and mine as well was Brad Pitt at home. Like I came home, I showed every friend, I had $500, nobody had $500. I had $500.
我觉得我要疯了，然后我妈把那张DVD没收了，不让我用，因为她说，这些人都是光着身子的。我说，妈，我在里面。我刚赚了500美元。她说，我不在乎。这根本没用。
I'm like, I'm losing my mind, and then my mom takes the DVD away from me and won't let me use it because she's like, these people are naked. I'm like, mom, I'm in the thing. I just got $500. She's like, I don't care. It should work.
这是垃圾。是的。这是垃圾。我们在飞机上，太恶心了。所以，好吧，事情正在发生。我稍微快进一下。对，对。
It's trash. Yeah. It's trash. We were on the airplane, and it was disgusting. Yeah. So, okay, things are happening. I'm fast forwarding a little bit. Yeah, yeah.
在高中时，我忽悠了一个人。我最喜欢的制作人之一。我也是。这人叫什么名字？肖恩也是这么说的。对，没错。我也是。我当时在MySpace上。
In high school, I trick a man. One of my favorite producers. Same. What's this guy named? Sean said that. Yeah, exactly. Same. I was on MySpace.
我联系了我最喜欢的制作人之一，我看到他在他的录音室里预订录音时间。他叫Disco D，我说，嘿，老兄，我喜欢你的作品，我想为你工作。他从没回复。然后我说，好吧，我要预订录音时间。然后他说，多少钱？于是我去了，我付给他一个小时的录音时间钱，
And I reached out to one of my favorite producers, and I saw he was booking studio time at his studio. His name was DiscoD, and I said, hey, man, I love your stuff, and I want to work for you. And he never answered. And then I said, okay, I want studio time. And then he said, how much? So I go up, I pay him for an hour of studio time,
然后我说，老兄，我不是要录音时间。我想为你工作。我愿意为你做世界上任何事。你让我做什么我都干。这家伙疯了。我不知道他为什么这么做。他说，我下周末要离开镇子。他说，如果你能把我的录音室未来三天的时间全部订满，你就有工作了。
and I'm like, dude, I don't want studio time. I want to work for you. I'll do anything for you in the world. I'll do whatever you say. This guy's crazy. I have no idea why he did this. He said, I'm leaving town next weekend. He said, if you can book my studio for three days, fully booked, you have a job.
你可以当我的实习生。我说，我当然能做到。首先，我根本不知道怎么做这事。我打了所有我认识的纽约人的电话。我找了所有的朋友。我literally，我借了，我记得我向我妈借了75美元来凑数，作为其中的一部分。然后……录音室一个小时多少钱？
You can be my intern. I said, of course I can do that. First of all, I had no idea how to do that. I called every person I knew in New York. I had every friend. I literally, I borrowed, I remember borrowing $75 for my mom to count, like, as part of the thing. And like... How much is studio time, like an hour?
天哪。是5000美元还是5美元？不，不，我想一天大概是500美元左右。或者也许是整个周末的钱。我甚至记不清了。但不知怎么的，我弄到了钱。而且我想我还差150美元。但我筹到了足够的钱。
That's, oh, my God. Is it like $5,000 or $5? No, no, I think it was like 500 for the day or something. Or maybe it was for the weekend. I can't even remember. But somehow I got the money. And I think I was like $150 short. But I got enough of the money.
他看到了。他让我去他那儿工作。我开始为他工作。我在我，你知道，17、18岁的时候搬到了纽约。我告诉我妈，你知道，我妈没有，我们没有，比如，她不能，比如，让我住在那种豪华的地方。这就好比。对。
And he saw it. He let me come work for him. I started working for him. I move out to New York when I'm, you know, 17, 18. I tell my mom, you know, my mom doesn't have, we don't, like, she can't, like, let me live in like a lavish plate. Like, it's like. Right.
所以我是，你住在哪里？我报名了一所音频工程学校。当时有这么个项目，你可以住在布鲁克林的圣乔治酒店（St. George Hotel）。这是一个为期六个月的项目。我和我妈凑钱付了学费。我赚了一些钱。然后她说，你只有这些了。那你自己想办法吧，之后我帮不了你了。
So I'm, where are you living? And I signed up for an audio engineering school. And there was like this thing where you could stay in like the St. George Hotel in Brooklyn. And it was like a six-month program. And I like split it with my mom. I had made some money. And then she was like, that's all you got. You got to figure it out then because I can't help you after that.
所以这很酷。我去了那里。我在为这家伙实习。Disco D。那真是个完美的时机，每个人，这就像是布鲁克林最后一次拥有那种蓬勃发展的独立圈子。所以当时的圈子就是我、迪普洛（Diplo）、M.I.A.、A-Track。这就像每个人都依然，我们都在努力闯出名堂。
So that's cool. I go out there. And I'm interning for this guy. Disco D. And it was just perfect timing of like everyone, this was like the last time Brooklyn had that like a scene that was growing. So it was like this was the scene was me, Diplo, MIA, A-Track. This was like everyone like still, we were all trying to make it.
就像每个人都在认真地做自己的事情。这就像那是一个非常酷的互联网博客圈。基本上，我当时为之工作、实习的那个家伙，他，你知道的，遭受了严重的精神疾病折磨。我跳过了很多细节，但他自杀身亡了。他就像是我最好的朋友。而且，我不知道该怎么办。但这也让我和他共事过的一些伙伴聚在了一起，我甚至，我恳求大家。
Like everyone was trying to do their thing justice. And it was like it was such a cool internet blog scene. And basically, the guy I was working for, who I was interning for, he, you know, suffered a lot of mental illness. And I'm skipping over a lot, but he committed suicide. And he was like my best friend. And like, I didn't know what to do. But it brought me together with a few of the guys that he was working with. And I, like, begged, begged people.
我会说：求求你们跟我合作吧。但不知为什么，没人愿意跟我合作。什么都没有。我尝试卖beat。什么屁用都没有。什么都没用。没人搭理，什么都没有。我记得当时在听一张混音带，有个家伙把声名狼藉先生（Notorious B.I.G.）的人声放在弗兰克·辛纳屈（Frank Sinatra）的伴奏上。我就觉得，这太酷了。这正值纳尔斯·巴克利（Gnarls Barkley）出道的时候。还记得那首歌吗？就像，这会让你发疯吗？对，哦天哪。完全是。所以这正是在这首歌发行的时候。我就想，我得弄个二人组合。这是我成功的唯一出路。我必须加入一个组合，一个二人组，我得采用采样并做类似这样的事情。所以我萌生了一个想法，我唯一个人认识的说唱歌手是一个叫Spank Rock的家伙，纳伊姆·朱安（Naim Jouan）。
I'd be like, please work with me. And somehow nobody would work with me. Nothing. I would try to sell bees. Nothing fucking worked. Nothing worked. No bites, nothing. And I remember listening to like a mixtape where this guy took like Notorious B.I.G. vocals and he put them over Frank Sinatra instrumentals. And I was like, that's so cool. And this was right when Narls Barclay came out. Remember that song? Like, does that make you crazy? Yeah, that's, oh my God. Totally. So it was right when this came out. And I was like, I got to become a duo. That's the only way I'm going to make it. I got to be in a. group duo, and I have to like take samples and do stuff like this. So I came up with an idea, and the only rapper I knew personally was this guy named Spank Rock, Naim Jouan.
他当时在业内很有热度。他当时是个大红人。他就像是拥有所有，他登上了，你知道的，《Fader》杂志的封面。他登上了《Complex》杂志。这就好像他是个大人物。我说，你必须跟我合作，但他就是不肯。不知为什么，在Disco D去世后，我们在我前经纪人的家里，
And he was like, he had like a lot of hype at that time. He was like a big thing at that time. He was like had all, he was on like, you know, the cover of Fader magazine. He was like on complex magazine. It was like he was a big thing. And I said, you got to work with me and he wouldn't do it. Somehow after DiscoD passed away, we were at my ex-manager's house,
我们当时只是在追忆过去。我说，老兄，求你了，你得跟我合作。我终于说服了他跟我合作一首歌。我们做了一首歌。什么都没发生。几周后，他打电话给我说，嘿，我知道这听起来很疯狂，但我们刚刚接到了一份唱片合约报价。
and we were just like reminiscing. And I said, dude, please, you got to work with me. I convinced him to make one song with me. We made one song. Nothing happened. A few weeks later, he called me and he said, hey, I know this is crazy, but we just got a record deal offer.
我说，你什么意思？那大约是我到纽约五个月的时候。我说，我什么意思？他说，对，我们收到了一份唱片合约报价，他们希望我们做你之前说的那张专辑。不会吧。是的，他说，叫Downtown唱片公司（Downtown Records）。
And I said, what do you mean? This was about five months into me being in New York. And I said, I said, What do you mean? He said, yeah, we got offered a record deal, and they want us to do the album you were talking about together. No way. Yeah, he said, and it's called Downtown Records.
最讽刺的是，纳尔斯·巴克利（Gnarls Barkley）就签约在同一家唱片公司。所以这种命运真是疯狂。哇，对，太疯狂了。所以我得到了这个机会。我在制作我的第一张专辑。这太超现实了。这太超现实了。我当时正在和所有我想合作的人合作。
The most ironic thing is Narls Barkley was signed to the same label. So like the fate is crazy. Wow, yeah, that is wild. So I get offered this opportunity. I'm making my first album. It's surreal. It's surreal. I'm working with everyone that I wanted to at the time.
这全都是很酷的地下音乐，然后突然我接到一个电话，他们说有个叫卢克博士（Dr. Luke）的人想见你，我说，卢克博士是谁？我什么都不知道。我不懂流行音乐。我说，卢克博士是谁？所以我去开会了。
It's all this cool underground thing. and then eventually I get a call and they say this guy named Dr. Luke wants to meet you and I said, who's Dr. Luke? I didn't know anything. I didn't know pop music. I said, who's Dr. Luke? So I go to the meeting.
我对他做过的事情一无所知。他做的是流行摇滚音乐。基本上，我觉得他在会面时恨透我了。我去了，我离开了会面。我回到这个景点的朋友那里。我说，老兄，我刚开了个会。我说，去他妈的这家伙。然后我接到一个电话。
I don't know anything of what he does. He does like pop rock music. Basically, I think he hates me in the meeting. I go, I leave the meeting. I go back to my friends at this view. I'm like, dude, I just did this meeting. I'm like, fuck this dude. And then I get a call.
我接到一个电话，他说，嘿，老兄，你明天晚上想来做点音乐吗？我说，什么？我说，我以为你讨厌我呢。你问我要小样，然后你甚至都没拿。然后他说，不，我只是知道你身上有某种特别的东西。所以我说，好吧，所以我去了，我和他一起工作。第二天，他说，你想跟我一起去洛杉矶
I get a call. and he's like, hey man, you want to come work on music tomorrow night? And I was like, what? I was like, I thought you hated me. You asked me for a demo, and then you didn't even take it. And then he's like, no, I just like knew that you had something special. So I was like, okay, so I go out, I work with him. The next day, he says, you want to come out to L.A. with me
去参与，比如，为小甜甜布兰妮（Britney Spears）之类的人制作音乐。我说，我当然知道。就像，我虽然不玩流行音乐，但我当然知道布兰妮·斯皮尔斯是谁。我说，什么？我说，你在说什么？他说，对，我和这个叫马克斯·马丁（Max Martin）的家伙一起工作。而我甚至不知道这些人都是谁。所以对任何听众来说，这些人都是泰坦巨头。
and work on, like, work on artists like Britney Spears and stuff like that. And I'm like, of course I knew. Like, I wasn't into pop music, but of course I knew who Britney Spears was. And I was like, what? I'm like, what are you talking about? And he's like, yeah, I work with this guy, Max Martin. And like, I didn't even know who any of these people are. So these are like, to anyone listening, these are like the Titans.
这些人就像是流行音乐的教父。比如马克斯·马丁拥有的冠军单曲数量最多，他的冠军单曲比披头士乐队还要多。所以我坐在那里。我他妈的一无所知。我到了那儿。那是我的第一天。我就想，老兄，我在写歌。我literally正和布兰妮·斯皮尔斯在录音室里。
These are like the godfathers of pop music. Like Max Martin has like the most number ones of, he has like more number ones than the Beatles. And so I'm sitting there. I know fucking nothing. I get out there. It's my first day. I'm like, dude, I'm making songs. I'm literally in the studio with Britney Spears.
我走进去，我走进去。而且这就像，我从来没见过狗仔队。我完全不知道。我走进去。我在布兰妮到达之前就进去了。所以我想，好吧，巴拉巴拉。然后我像是在外面打个电话，好吧？我在这间录音室里，它有点像在丛林里。
I walk in, I walk in. And this is like, I had never seen paparazzi. I had no idea. I walk in. I go in before Brittany gets there. So I'm like, okay, blah, blah, blah. Then I'm like out making a phone call, okay? And I'm in this studio that's like kind of in like a jungle.
它叫康威录音室（Conway Studios）。我不知道你有没有去过。它在洛杉矶。它是个很酷的室内室外结合的录音室。所以我正在停车场里走来走去。一个男人从类似蹦极绳索的东西上降下来。他拍了一张照片。
It's called Conway Studios. I don't know if you've ever been there. It's in L.A. And it's like a cool like indoor outdoor studio. So I'm walking around in the parking lot. And a man comes down from like a bungee cord. And he snaps a picture of. of my face.
拍了我的脸。
And I was like, what the fuck is going on? And then, like, all of a sudden, like, a security guard tackles the man. And I'm like, and that's like my first, and I'm like, whoa, okay, I guess I'm in Hollywood now.
当时我就想，这他妈是怎么回事？然后，突然间，有个保安把那个男的扑倒了。然后我想，那就是我的第一次，我想，哇，好吧，我想我现在在好莱坞了。
And it's like, yeah, like, my first week, I'm, like, going to clubs with, like, Paris Hilton. Like, it's like, things are like, it's all moving. When did you, when did you pretend to be Jay Z's attorney? Like, what part of the time?
就像是，第一周，我就和帕丽斯·希尔顿（Paris Hilton）一起去夜店。就像，事情在发展，一切都在推进。你是什么时候，你是什么时候假装自己是Jay-Z的律师的？大概是什么时候？
That was like, 13. Oh, okay, okay. I thought that was later. I'm skipping, I'm skipping around. I'm part of it. I'm party with Paris, man. We can't talk about Jason. That's funny.
那是大概13岁的时候。哦，好吧，好吧。我还以为那是后来呢。我跳过了，我在东拉西扯。这是其中一部分。我和帕丽斯在派对狂欢，老兄。我们不能聊杰森。太搞笑了。
Wow. So I'm 18. Yeah. I put the music. I put the rapping behind. I'm now, oh, first of all, I'm in the studio. I've never written a song for another pop artist ever. I'm in the studio with Dr. Luke and a guy named Claude Kelly.
哇。所以当时我18岁。对。我把说唱抛在脑后了。我现在，哦，首先，我在录音室里。我从来没有为其他流行歌手写过一首歌。我和卢克博士以及一个叫克劳德·凯利（Claude Kelly）的家伙在录音室里。
And Claude goes, well, now we got to write the song. And I said, I don't know how to write a song. I said, I know how to rap. And he said, okay, well, well, why don't you rap and we'll like put melodies to it at the same time. And the first song we ever wrote together was circus for Britney Spears. And so it was like... Yeah, I mean, for Trace, well, you guys too, you might not know Dr. Luke.
克劳德说，好吧，现在我们得写歌了。我说，我不会写歌。我说，我会说唱。他说，好吧，那为什么你不一边说唱，我们一边把旋律加进去呢。我们一起写的歌第一首是为布兰妮·斯皮尔斯写的《Circus》。所以就像是……对，我是说，对翠丝（Trace）来说，你们可能也不知道卢克博士。
He produced like, since you've been, since you've been gone, you know that... Everything. Him and Max... I kissed a girl. It came in like a racking ball from My Osiris and... Yeah. Tons of him. And Max Martin produced every song for Britney...
他制作了，比如《Since U Been Gone》，你知道那个……一切。他和马克斯……《I Kissed a Girl》。还有来自麦莉·赛勒斯（Miley Cyrus）的《Wrecking Ball》……对。有大量的作品。而且马克斯·马丁为布兰妮制作了每一首歌……
Hit me, baby, one more time. Yeah, every song for the back. On it that way. Every in sync song. Yeah, like all the new Taylor Swift stuff. He does, he does a lot on the weekend. Like, so, okay, so I'm sitting in the room with these guys, and it's like the biggest imposter syndrome in the world.
《...Baby One More Time》。对，为后街男孩（Backstreet Boys）制作了每一首歌。《Everybody (Backstreet's Back)》。每一首超级男孩（NSYNC）的歌。对，还有泰勒·斯威夫特（Taylor Swift）所有的新歌。他做过，他在威肯（The Weeknd）身上也做了很多。所以，好吧，我坐在这些家伙的房间里，这简直是世界上最大程度的冒名顶替综合征。
I have no idea what I'm fucking doing. I'm 18 years old. These guys are like 40. Like, and I'm, and I'm, and I'm, but, but the thing that's cool is the artists all are really young. So they look at me. I'm like, like, and so like, Max is. like, hey, like, go get the artist to do this song. And I'm like the cool guy who like goes out to the clubs and like knows where the cool food is.
我他妈完全不知道自己在干什么。我才18岁。这些家伙都40岁左右。就像，而且我，而且我，而且我，但很酷的一点是，这些艺人都非常年轻。所以他们看着我。就像，而且所以，马克斯会说，嘿，去叫艺人来录这首歌。而我就像是个很酷的家伙，会去夜店，还知道哪里有好吃的。
Well, you've got the street cred. You know what I mean? Yeah. And I'm, yes, and I'm coming from doing like cool underground stuff with like Diplo and Santi Gold and MIA. So, so it kind of started this thing. And, you know, before I know it, I'm like making all these songs. That's what I tell all these people. They're like, well, I'm not classically true.
好吧，你很有街头信誉。你知道我的意思吗？对。而且我是，是的，我之前做的是和迪普洛（Diplo）、桑蒂·戈德（Santi Gold）、M.I.A.合作的那种很酷的地下音乐。所以，这算是开启了这一切。而且，不知不觉中，我写了所有这些歌。这就是我告诉所有这些人的。他们会说，好吧，我不是科班出身。
I'm not this. Guys, I'm like barely a musician. I just like, I'm sure you guys are the same way. I fudged my way completely into what I'm doing. Like, I just faked it and learned on the fucking job. But you have taste and you know how, you know what sounds good, you know how to create that, you know how to maintain it if you do hear it and you know how to add to it, right? Yeah, A, A, there's that.
我不是那种人。伙计们，我根本算不上是个音乐人。我只是，我确信你们也是一样。我完全是靠着瞎混才混到了今天的地步。就像，我只是伪装自己，然后在工作中边干边学。但你有品味，你知道怎么，你知道什么听起来好听，你知道怎么创作它，如果你听到了，你知道怎么保持它，而且你知道怎么给它锦上添花，对吧？对，A，A，有这方面的原因。
100% there is that because you had it and you all, it sounds like you came from it. naturally. There's always music we covered. And the sort of the through line is, is none of this was, when you said, ironically, you ended up at the same place as Narz Barkley, is you created your own, you manifested it by working hard. It didn't happen by accident, dude.
100%有这方面的原因，因为你拥有它，而且你们所有人都，听起来你像是自然而然拥有这一切。我们总是涉猎各种音乐。而贯穿其中的主线是，这一切都不是，就像你刚才说的具有讽刺意味的是，你最终和纳尔斯·巴克利（Gnarls Barkley）到了同一个地方，那就是你创造了你自己的命运，你通过努力工作把这一切变成了现实。这不是偶然发生的，老兄。
You, every step of the way, you hustled, and you created those opportunities for yourself by continuing 100%. I know what you're saying. I know what you're saying. Like I always tell people, the harder you work, the more chance. is you have to be lucky. Yeah.
你在每一步中，都在拼搏，你通过不断努力为自己创造了那些机会，100%是这样。我明白你的意思。我明白你的意思。就像我总是对人们说的那样，你越努力，你走运的几率就越大。对。
Like you didn't want to go and live, like going to stay and do that engineering program where you get a room in Brooklyn. That led to a bunch of other shit. Of course. Right, right. How do you get that? Well, you got to do, like as you said before,
就像你本来不想去住，比如去参加那个音频工程项目，在布鲁克林弄个房间。那却引出了后面一堆的事。当然。对，对。你怎么得到的？好吧，你得去做，就像你刚才说的，
you've got to do these little step, these little bullshit things. Yeah, I thought it was going to be the biggest rapper in the world. Yeah. Yeah, yeah. Yeah. Like, here's what I'll say for you, for you guys, though. Seriously.
你必须经历这些微小的步骤，这些微不足道的破事。对，我本以为自己会成为世界上最伟大的说唱歌手。对。对，对。对。比如，不过我要对你们说的是，说真的。
Like, okay, all of you guys, I'm sure, have the same answer. Like, are you the best, actor, like, is there someone out there who's a better actor than you? Are there people that you feel are more deserving? A million. Yes, yes. But, like, you're talented, and you guys have, like, to me, it's like, you guys have, like, great vibe.
比如，好吧，你们所有人，我确信，都有同样的答案。比如，你是最棒的演员吗？比如，外面有没有比你更好的演员？有没有人让你觉得比你更配得上这一切？无数个。是的，是的。但是，比如，你很有才华，而且你们有，对我来说，这就好像，你们有，比如，极佳的氛围。
You have great rap. You have great talk. And it's, like, I think so much of it is, like, a person's energy, their work ethic, mixed with a little bit of talent. You have to have, like, some talent. But I think so much of it is like. People skills. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
你们很有说服力。你们很会聊天。而且，我觉得很大程度上，这取决于一个人的能量、职业道德，再加上一点点天赋。你必须得有，比如，一些天赋。但我认为很大程度上这取决于。人际交往能力。对，对，对。
And, Benny, go ahead. You go. I have nothing to say. Okay. No, I wanted to get to, because we're running out of time and I don't want to take all your time. I think he had all the time in the fucking world. Also, that was an hour ago.
然后，本尼，你继续。你来。我无话可说。好吧。不，我想切入正题，因为我们时间不多了，我不想占用你所有的时间。我觉得他有的是他妈的时间。而且，那是一个小时前的事了。
The truth is, for me, is also, I'm a really good lay. Yeah. I can tell you, look, you're hot. You guys are all so beautiful. Thanks, man. You are too. Benny. We'll be right back.
事实是，对我来说，我也是个很好说话的人。对。我可以告诉你，听着，你很性感。你们所有人都太美了。谢谢，老兄。你也是。本尼。我们马上回来。
All right, back to the show. I wanted to, because I'm obsessed with your wife, just like you are, just like millions of people are. And I really, really am such a big fan of Salinas. How did you meet? By the way, Betty just passed her for me. I mean, we don't know each other, Benny. This is, of course, for me.
好了，回到节目中。我想要，因为我跟你一样迷恋你的妻子，就像成千上万的人一样。我真的，真的是赛琳娜（Selena）的超级大粉丝。你们是怎么认识的？顺便说一句，贝蒂刚才替我转达了。我是说，我们不认识彼此，本尼。这当然是代表我。
I'd like to officially ask for your friendship. You don't have to answer now, but, yeah, I'd like you a part of my life, please. Guys, first of all, before I say, say anything about my wife. I do want to say the amount of what I do, the amount that I've learned from all of you guys, like through what you guys do. Like, and this isn't a joke.
我想正式请求你的友谊。你现在不用回答，但是，对，我希望你能成为我生活中的一部分，拜托。伙计们，首先，在我说任何关于我妻子的事之前。我确实想说，我所做的一切，我从你们所有人身上学到的东西，通过你们所做的事情。就像，这不是在开玩笑。
Like, like, like, I've, first of all, I've seen every single rest of development episode ever. Second of all, I've watched, I watched Ozark three different times because I had to show so many different people. Selena and I, every single night we go to bed
就像，就像，首先，我看过《发展受阻》（Arrested Development）的每一集。其次，我看过，我把《黑钱胜地》（Ozark）看了三遍，因为我不得不向好多不同的人安利。赛琳娜和我，我们每天晚上入睡时
to Will and Grace every single night no matter what it's like it's first of all I love the show but that's her doing I'm not watching Will and Grace every single fucking night
都要看《威尔和格蕾丝》（Will & Grace），无论如何每天晚上都看。首先我很喜欢这部剧，但那是她的功劳，我可不是每天晚上他妈的都在看《威尔和格蕾丝》
in my life no no every straight guy says the same thing yeah I can say the Sean we have a quick visit from Jack can you visit your character but it's so funny everybody it's so funny straight guys always coming to me
的生活中，不，不，每个直男都说同样的话。对，我可以对肖恩说，杰克（Jack）来过我们这儿做过客，你能探访一下你的角色吗？但这太搞笑了，每个人，这太搞笑了，直男们总是跑来对我说
like my wife I mean, I don't watch it with her, but I, but then, you know, but then they quote it. I watched it with my mother and then I've rewatched it now 700 times with my wife. Okay, so how did I meet, how did I meet my wife? Yeah, yeah, yeah. Funny part is, first time we met, neither one of us remember. There's an email that exists, but we can't remember because we were both young.
就像我老婆，我是说，我不跟她一起看，但是，但是然后呢，你知道的，但然后他们会引用里面的台词。我和我妈妈一起看了它，然后我现在和我老婆一起重温了700遍。好吧，那么我是怎么遇到，我是怎么遇到我老婆的？对，对，对。有趣的是，我们第一次见面时，我们俩都不记得了。确实存在一封电子邮件，但我们记不得了，因为我们当时都还年轻。
Her mother, I was already like pretty successful as a producer, okay? and she hadn't really made music yet. She's a few years younger than me. So she was a star on Disney, and she had just started, I think, making like Disney songs, but they weren't like, no one was taking her seriously as like a pop star. Right.
她的母亲，当时我已经是一个相当成功的制作人了，好吧？而她当时还没怎么做过音乐。她比我小几岁。所以她是迪士尼的明星，她刚开始，我想，制作一些迪士尼的歌曲，但它们不是，当时没有人把她当成严肃的流行巨星来看待。对。
And somehow her mother, being like the hustler she is, got a meeting with me. And I don't remember that meeting, but we had a meeting. It existed. There's, like, email, there's emails. And that was, oh, my God, that was. at least 15 years ago, maybe more. Asking you to produce her stuff?
不知怎么的，她的母亲凭着那股闯劲，跟我开了一个会。我不记得那个会了，但我们确实开过会。它存在过，有，比如，电子邮件，有电子邮件。那是，天哪，那是。至少15年以前了，也许更久。请你为她的作品担任制作人？
Something like that. But in 2014, one of my closest friends signed her to a record deal at Interscope Records. His name's John Janick. I also have my own record label there, and that's where I put out my music. And he said, we signed this girl, Selena. And I was like, oh, yeah, I love her stuff. Like she was getting big, and she was, it was, and I was like, oh, I love her stuff. I didn't even know about the TV show.
差不多吧。但在2014年，我最亲密的朋友之一把她签到了新视镜唱片公司（Interscope Records）的唱片合约。他叫约翰·贾尼克（John Janick）。我在那儿也有自己的唱片公司，我就是在那里发行我的音乐的。他说，我们签了这个女孩，赛琳娜。我说，哦，对，我喜欢她的作品。当时她正变得越来越火，而这正是，当时我就想，哦，我喜欢她的作品。我甚至不知道那个电视节目。
Didn't know any of that. Because I'm too old for it. It was over my head. So we get put together and we make a few songs. We have a really big hit song called Same Old Love. And that's 2014. And over the next few years, we have made a few songs. Like, friend is like the loosest term in the world.
对这一切一无所知。因为我年纪太大了。这超出了我的认知范围。所以我们被安排到一起，做了一些歌。我们有一首非常火的热门歌曲叫《Same Old Love》。那是2014年。在接下来的几年里，我们又做了一些歌。“朋友”这个词就像是世界上最宽泛的定义。
Like acquaintances that spend extended period of times in the studio together. But nothing more than that. Then in 2019, we did a song together and I had become an artist, okay? So I had been putting out songs as an artist. We do a song together. It's called I Can't Get Enough and it has Tiny on it and it has Jay Balvin on it. And it's a really cool song. And we're shooting the music video.
就像是在录音室里共度大量时间的泛泛之交。但仅此而已。然后在2019年，我们一起合作了一首歌，当时我已经成为了一名艺人，好吧？所以我一直以艺人的身份发行歌曲。我们合作了一首歌。它叫《I Can't Get Enough》，里面有J Balvin，还有Tainy。这是一首很酷的歌。我们在拍音乐录影带。
Okay. And she was going through a tough time at that time. It was a very tough time. and she they had all these rules I thought like and it was like you know when like you're getting like second hand information from someone and they're like yeah and like when she like don't talk about this thing and don't say too much of that and like maybe like if she looks like and it's like I'm sure you guys get that with stuff like through the podcast or like even people say that about you and then um so I'm like there and I'm like okay what am I'm like looking at the things I'm not supposed to say
好吧。她当时正经历一段艰难的时期。那是一段非常艰难的时期。而她，他们有各种各样的规矩，我以为，就像是当你从某人那里听到二手信息，他们会说，对，当她像这样时——不要谈论这件事，不要说太多那个，也许像如果她看起来像——这就像，我确信你们在播客中也会遇到这种事，或者甚至人们也会这样谈论你们。然后，嗯，所以我去了那儿，我想，好吧，我在看那些我不能说的话题。
And I get up there and we just immediately, like we had hung out, but we hit it off in like a level that's so fun. I have a girlfriend at the time. Not like, this isn't like sexually or romantically. Like we just hit it off and I'm like, wow, I'm like, dude. I'm like, she's fucking cool. I'm like, Selena, it's like the first time where like we actually like hung out and got deep. And like there's like a picture.
我一到那儿，我们立刻就——虽然我们之前一起混过，但我们一拍即合，那种感觉太有趣了。我当时有个女朋友。不是那种，这跟性和浪漫无关。我们就是一拍即合，我心想，哇，我心想，老兄。我心想，她他妈的太酷了。我心想，赛琳娜，这是我们第一次真正地一起混并深入交流。而且有一张照片。
By the way, she insulted. You're like, finally you're like after years like, hey, you know what? You're cool. And she's like, hey, thanks a lot. Yeah, finally. No, no, no, she wasn't because it's like, she's like, you know, in a studio sometimes. And, like, just like someone at her level, you can be a little bit guarded in a situation. And, like, I really got, were you saying?
顺便说一句，她冒犯了你。你就像是，历经多年之后你终于说：“嘿，你知道吗？你挺酷的。”而她却说：“嘿，多谢啊。”对，终于。不，不，不，她没有，因为这就好像，她在录音室里有时。而且，就像一个处于她那个地位的人，在这种情况下你可能会有些防备心。而且，我真的，你在说什么？
I was just saying I read that when she used to show up to your house a little early and sit outside and, like, fix herself and talk to her friend on the phone before he was going in because she was so nervous. And you knew it because you had cameras outside. And you see her. That was after we started dating. So like literally. That is really funny. Okay.
我只是在说，我读到过，当她以前早早来到你家，坐在外面，整理自己，在进去之前跟朋友打电话，因为她太紧张了。而你心知肚明，因为你在外面装了摄像头。你看到了她。那是我们开始约会之后的事了。所以简直是。这真的太搞笑了。好吧。
So basically I'm at my photo. I'm at my shoot. I'm at my shoot. And my mother comes up to me. She says, you should really date someone like Selena. I think you should date. I said, mom. I said, I have a girlfriend right now.
所以基本上我在拍照。我在拍摄现场。我在拍摄现场。我妈妈向我走来。她说，你真该和赛琳娜这样的人约会。我觉得你应该约会。我说，妈。我说，我现在有女朋友了。
What are you talking about? And she goes, no, no. But like, you should really end up with someone like Selena. And I was like, mom, what do you? And I'm like saying like you're crazy. Okay. 2020. We don't even have to get into it because the whole internet knows.
你在说什么呢？她却说，不，不。但就像，你真的应该跟赛琳娜这样的人在一起。我说，妈，你在搞什么？我当时觉得你疯了。好吧。2020年。我们甚至不必深入讨论它，因为整个互联网都知道。
There was like some sort of thing where the internet thought I meant one thing, and I obviously didn't mean it. And they thought I was like taking a dig at Selena. Okay? And it's like you don't need to waste the time. It's been like talked about so many times. They thought I was taking a personal dig at Selena on like a radio show. And obviously I wasn't, I've never taken a dig at any human being in my life.
当时发生了一些事情，互联网以为我指的是一件事，而我显然不是那个意思。他们以为我在挖苦赛琳娜。好吧？这就好像你不需要浪费时间。这件事已经被讨论过太多次了。他们以为我在某个电台节目中对赛琳娜进行了人身攻击。而我显然没有，我这辈子从来没有挖苦过任何人。
Right, right, right. So things maybe seem a little weird. And, like, I, like, am going to text her. And then, like, my friend's like, no, just don't. It's fine. And then I see her over the next few years a few times at, like, parties or I run into her. And then, like, sometimes it's like, oh, my God, hey. And sometimes it's like, oh, was that awkward?
对，对，对。所以事情看起来可能有点奇怪。而且，就像，我打算给她发信息。然后，就像，我朋友说，不，别发了。没事的。然后我在接下来的几年里在派对上见过她几次，或者偶然遇到她。然后，有时候就像是，哦，天哪，嘿。有时就像是，哦，刚才那场面很尴尬吗？
Was that in my head? Was it? So, like, I, like, don't know what's going on. And then, 2023, she's making a song called Singles Soon. And some of my guys had written the song, okay? Yeah. And I heard it, and I was like, oh, I'm not a huge fan of this song, but let me help you guys, like, make it better.
那是我的臆想吗？是吗？所以，就像，我根本不知道发生了什么。然后，到了2023年，她正在制作一首歌叫《Single Soon》。我的一些伙伴写了这首歌，好吧？对。我听了，我说，哦，我不是这首歌的超级粉丝，但让我帮你们把它做得更好一点。
And John calls me up, and he said, okay, he said, but was there some weird thing with you and Selena, like, that we should straighten out? And I was like, I don't think so. We were cool the last time we saw each other. And then he was like, maybe you should go to the studio and just, like, show face and, like, just like make things all good. And I'm like, okay.
然后约翰打电话给我，他说，好吧，他说，你和赛琳娜之间是不是有什么奇怪的事情，我们需要把它理清楚？我说，我觉得没有。我们上次见面时关系挺好的。然后他说，也许你应该去录音室露个面，然后把事情都化解好。我说，好吧。
And then he was like, I don't think they're bad, but, like, maybe just make them go. good. And I'm like, okay. So I go to the studio, I hang out. We like hit it off. So we're like laughing. Whether she hated me before or not, whatever is erased. We're like, we're laughing. But, but like so not in a romantic way. Like we're laughing in a way where I'm like, oh my God, I have dinners all the time with my friends. You should come over. I'll hook you up with a great guy. By the way, I read a description of one of your dinners where your mom's in a rhinestone shirt that says Bada Bing and people are, and people are. And people are.
然后他说，我觉得情况没那么糟，但也许还是去把事情搞好吧。我说，好吧。所以我去了录音室，一起闲逛。我们一拍即合。所以我们都在笑。不管她以前是否讨厌我，一切都一笔勾销了。我们都在笑，但并不是以一种浪漫的方式。我们大笑的方式让我觉得，哦天哪，我经常和朋友们吃晚餐。你应该过来。我给你介绍个好小伙。顺便说一句，我读过你其中一次晚宴的描述，你妈妈穿着一件印有“Bada Bing”字样的水钻衬衫，人们都在，人们都在。人们都在。
And people are tripping on Toad? What is Toad? What is Toad? Wait, let him fair. Wait, I want to hear. You're so well read about all the time. Toad is a thing where you like slip. His assistant is busy.
人们都在嗑“蛤蟆”（Toad）？什么是蛤蟆？什么是蛤蟆？等等，让他说公平点。等等，我想听。你对所有这些八卦了解得真多。蛤蟆是一种让你产生幻觉的东西。他的助手正忙着呢。
Yeah, really busy, believe. It's where you fucking slip into another dimension. Read about it when you're trying to take a shit next time. Okay. Very good, very good. Here's where we're at. So I'm in there. We're doing it.
对，真的很忙，相信我。这就是那种让你他妈的滑入另一个维度的东西。下次你拉屎的时候读读看吧。好吧，很好，很好。我们现在进展到这儿了。所以我进去了。我们在做这事。
I leave the thing. I leave the session. I write her like a message, just smoothing everything over, saying like, so glad we got in Sue. I had like the best time ever. And we start talking back and forth. And it was just like, you know, to me like simple artist talk. And then like she starts sending like funny selfies back and forth.
我离开了那个地方。我离开了那次创作。我给她发了一条信息，只是把所有事情都平息了一下，说很高兴我们一起合作了。我度过了有史以来最棒的时光。然后我们开始来回发信息。这就好像，你知道的，对我来说就像是简单的艺人聊天。然后她开始发一些搞笑的自拍。
And I'm still, I'm like in the middle of doing a bunch of stuff. So I don't really like pay it much mind. I'm just like, oh, this is just like friendly banter. And then she asks me to hang out the next day. She said, do you want to hang out? And I said, oh, I said, yo, I'm, I got my friends' birthday dinner. You want to come with me? And I'm thinking it's friends because I'm like, obviously Selena Gomez doesn't want to go out on a date with me.
而我还在，我正忙着处理一堆事情。所以我其实并没有太放在心上。我只是觉得，哦，这只是朋友间的调侃而已。然后她问我第二天要不要一起出去玩。她说，你想出去玩吗？我说，哦，我说，哟，我有我朋友的生日晚宴。你想跟我一起去吗？我以为这只是朋友聚会，因为我想，显然赛琳娜·戈麦斯不可能想跟我去约会。
And I had no idea. I had no, I'm obviously. We're going to get to the date soon, right? Yeah, we're getting to the date. Okay. We're getting to the date right now. Why, you got to go to take a poop or something? So, okay, we're at the date.
我根本不知道。我完全不知道。我们很快就要讲到约会了吧？对，我们要讲到约会了。好吧。我们现在就要讲到约会了。怎么，你得去拉屎还是怎么的？所以，好吧，我们在约会。
We're at the date. It's Friday. She thinks it's a date. I have no idea it's a date, okay? And she makes a comment where I'm like, is this a date? But I don't know. And then we're, because we're with other people. Like, first we got a glass of wine, then we're with other people.
我们在约会。那是星期五。她以为这是一场约会。我完全不知道这是一场约会，好吧？她发表了一个评论，让我想，这是一场约会吗？但我不知道。然后我们，因为我们跟其他人在一起。首先我们喝了一杯酒，然后我们和其它人在一起。
And she, like, leaves suddenly early. And I'm like, oh, okay, I guess it wasn't a date. And she's like, I got to shoot a music video. tomorrow. And I said, okay. And then I'm like, oh, she's just like super busy and that we were just friends. And then she texted me, she's like, that was the best time I've had in a really long time. And I'm like, oh, yeah, that's so fun. Then we go out on a second date. Then I'm like, oh, this is a date. And I lay a smooch on her. And we literally, since that day, have been inseparable. She's the yin to my yang. She's my best. And she's, and we're, and
然后她突然很早就走了。然后我就想，哦，好吧，我想这不算是一次约会。然后她说，我明天得去拍音乐录影带。我说，好吧。然后我想，哦，她只是超级忙，我们只是朋友。然后她给我发短信，说那是她好久以来过得最开心的一次。然后我想，哦，太好了，那太有趣了。然后我们进行了第二次约会。然后我想，哦，这是一次约会。然后我亲了她一下。从那天起，我们几乎形影不离。她是我的灵魂伴侣。她是我的挚友。然后她，我们，然后
friend. I know she's been on your guys thing. She's the easiest person to talk to on planet Earth. She's so much smarter than me. She's so much funnier than me. She's definitely so much prettier than me. I just love how open and honest you both are and you both seem so comfortable in your skin and just like, look, I'm just human and I'm just me and like, you know, I'm just trying to get on with it, you know? It seems like it's just such a great, a great match the two of you. Yeah, you're lucky. You guys are both such genuine people. People always say things. They're like, what?
朋友。我知道她上过你们的节目。她是地球上最容易交谈的人。她比我聪明得多。她比我有趣得多。她绝对比我漂亮得多。我只是喜欢你们两个是多么的坦诚和真诚，你们看起来都那么自在，就像是，听着，我只是个人，我只是我自己，就像是，你知道的，我只是想继续过下去，你知道吗？你们俩看起来真是太般配了。是的，你们很幸运。你们两个都是如此真诚的人。人们总是说一些话。他们会说，什么？
They're like, okay, but like, what do you guys do on like a normal night? And I'm like, what do you do on a normal night? I'm like, what do you do on a normal night? Like, after this, like, what am I going to do? I'm going to sit on a couch with her and watch a movie and maybe I'll make her dinner. I love that. Benny, you know, we've got to let you go because we've taken what boys
他们会说，好吧，但是，你们普通的一个晚上都在做些什么？我就想，你们普通的一个晚上都在做些什么？我说，你们普通的一个晚上都在做些什么？就像，在这之后，我要做什么？我要和她在沙发上一起看电影，也许我会给她做晚饭。我喜欢这样。班尼，你知道的，我们得让你走了，因为我们已经占用了
for much of your time. But I saw on your website, you'll sell someone a strand of your hair for 4,900. $95 or your actual phone, passcode, photos, and contacts for a million dollars. Has anybody tried to buy either one? So that was the thing from like nine years ago when I first became an artist. And it went like super viral back then. Yeah.
你很多时间。但我看到在你的网站上，你会以4995美元的价格向别人出售你的一缕头发，或者以一百万美元的价格出售你真正的手机、密码、照片和联系人。有没有人试图买过其中任何一个？所以那是大约九年前我刚成为艺术家时的事情。当时在网上超级火爆。是的。
Does anybody call and bought it yet? I don't even think you can hit the link. You want it for free. You can just have either one. Okay, great. I love that. I'll send it over. And your new album Hermoso, which is, I don't even.
有没有人打电话买过？我甚至觉得你都点不开那个链接。你想要的话是免费的。你两个都可以拿去。好的，太好了。我喜欢这样。我发给你。还有你的新专辑《Hermoso》，那是，我甚至。
I listen to some of it is really, really, really, really cool. I love it. I also have a book. I got a book. Oh, yeah, the book, yeah. I have a book. It's called fuck failure? Is that what it's going?
我听了一些，真的，真的，真的很酷。我很喜欢。我还有一本书。我有一本书。哦，对，那本书，对。我有一本书。书名叫《操纵失败》？是叫这个吗？
Yes. Yes. Like, yeah, I have a book on just like how to fail upwards, you know? Oh, I like that. That's out now? It probably will be when this thing's out. Yeah. Let's just say, watch, watch this.
是的。是的。就像，对，我有一本关于如何通过失败实现向上的书，你知道的？哦，我喜欢这个。现在出版了吗？这个节目播出的时候可能已经出版了吧。对。这么说吧，看着，看着这个。
My new book's out right now. Go ahead. Okay, now watch this. Now watch this. My new books coming out. soon. You should get it soon. Yeah. Now watch you. Yeah, yeah.
我的新书现在出版了。请吧。好吧，现在看这个。现在看这个。我的新书快要出版了。很快。你应该快点去买。对。现在轮到你了。对，对。
Just insert them right. Benny, but there's not a lot of people on the planet with your success. So I'm just so blown away by your story and how you got here and all the contributions you've made to society through music. Like it's, everybody
直接插进去就行。班尼，地球上像你这样取得成功的人并不多。所以我真的对你的故事、你是如何走到这里的，以及你通过音乐为社会做出的所有贡献感到无比震撼。就像是，每个人
knows your songs. It's got to be the best feeling in the world. And how earned it is. Yeah, yeah. It's really impressive. Truly, truly, truly, truly, I mean it. It's so well-earned. and deserved because you worked really, really hard and you really... I don't like compliments.
都知道你的歌。这一定是世界上最棒的感觉。而且这是你应得的。对，对。真的令人印象深刻。真的，真的，真的，我是认真的。这是你应得的，因为你真的、真的很努力，而且你真的……我不喜欢恭维。
Say something really bad about it. Say something terrible about them. I never get them. I never get them, so I don't know. When do you sail back to the States? I sail back in September. I'm going back in September because I got to go promote my book in New York
说点关于它的极其糟糕的话。说点关于它们的糟糕的话。我从来没有得到过赞美。我从来没有得到过，所以我不知道。你什么时候乘船回美国？我九月份乘船回去。我九月份回去，因为我要去纽约宣传我的书
and then I'm really taking some time off. I won't have been home in four and a half months. Is New York home or Los Angeles? No, Los Angeles is home. and I just want to like Oh my God Yeah I haven't I haven't slept in my bed in almost five months
然后我真的要休个假。我已经有四个半月没回家了。纽约是你的家还是洛杉矶？不，洛杉矶才是家，我只想，天啊，是的，我差不多五个月没在自己的床上睡过了
Yeah I just finished Are you guys thinking what I'm thinking The four of us New York to L.A. road trip? Oh shit Where do you guys live? Are you all L.A.? Yes, yes Yes Both.
是的，我刚结束。你们在想我和你想的一样吗？我们四个人去纽约到洛杉矶的公路旅行？哦，靠。你们住在哪里？你们都是洛杉矶人吗？是的，是的，是的。都是。
Can I hang out with you guys? Yeah, right when you get back Yeah, please coming up with us I missed the last hangout But I want I'm going to be a big part of the next one Is this fake? No, it's real. Are we, is there actual, like, will I ever actually have your guys' numbers?
我可以和你们一起出去玩吗？对，你一回来就去。对，求你了，跟我们一起来。我错过了上次的聚会。但我想，我会成为下一次聚会的重要组成部分。这是假的吗？不，这是真的。我们，会有实际的，就像，我以后真的会有你们的电话号码吗？
There's this a thing we're talking about on here, and then we never speak ever again. Be honest. I'll love you either way. I would be killed to hang out with you. All kinds of weird things. We're going to forward you. We're going to text you. It's going to be awkward.
这是我们在这里讨论的一件事，然后我们就再也不联系了吗？说实话。无论如何我都爱你。能和你们一起出去玩我会高兴死的。各种奇怪的事情。我们会转发给你。我们会给你发短信。那会很尴尬的。
Here, I'm going to tell you guys something. Your phone number? Right now. No, just, yeah, I'm telling you my number right now. I'm about to go on Howard Stern by the time this airs. If you guys haven't texted me by the time I go on Howard Stern, I'm literally airing you out on Howard's turn. So I'm just letting you, I'm just letting you know that
听着，我要告诉你们一件事。你们的电话号码？现在吗？不，只是，是的，我现在把我的号码告诉你们。等这个节目播出的时候，我差不多就要上霍华德·斯特恩的节目了。如果在我上霍华德·斯特恩的节目之前你们没有给我发短信，我真的会在霍华德的节目里把你们曝光。所以我只是让你们知道，我只是让你们知道
because I'm a people's people, and I got to let the people know if this thing's really going to have it. We're going to cut it. Give us your phone number right now. Okay. We'll write it down old school cell. We'll cut it. Okay.
因为我是一个亲民的人，我必须让大家知道这事是不是真的会发生。我们要剪掉它。现在就把你的电话号码给我们。好吧。我们用老式的手机记下来。我们要剪掉它。好吧。
Are you going to write it down with a pen? Yeah, I got a pen. Me too. Hey, guys, don't cut it. Guys, don't cut it. Yeah, yeah, don't cut it. Whatever you do not cut that. I can't believe he fell for it.
你们要用笔写下来吗？对，我有一支笔。我也是。嘿，伙计们，别剪掉。伙计们，别剪掉。对，对，千万别剪掉那个。真不敢相信他居然上当了。
leaked that number by mistake like four times. And I just like, I just, my phone just rings all day. And by the way, you know what? By the way, you know what the thing is, anybody can have my number. It doesn't mean I'm going to respond. I know. I know. My phone just rings all day.
因为失误不小心把那个号码泄露了大概四次。然后我就，我的手机整天都在响。顺便说一句，你知道吗？顺便说一句，你知道是怎么回事吗，任何人都可以有我的号码。这并不意味着我会回复。我知道。我知道。我的手机整天都在响。
Holy shit. Whoa, dude, that was deep as fuck. You guys are actually amazing. Benny, we love you. Thank you so much. Hey, listen. How about we go to the studio? Yes. And you guys, and also, you guys, I don't know if you've seen it, but like, you guys really
见鬼。哇，老弟，这真是深奥得要命。你们俩真的很棒。班尼，我们爱你。非常感谢。嘿，听着。我们去录音室怎么样？好啊。而且你们，还有，你们，我不知道你们有没有看过，但是像，你们真的
inspired me and Dave and his wife to have a podcast. We have a podcast. Oh, great. And you guys really inspired us to do it because we were like, oh, podcasts are so stupid. And then once we saw you guys do it, we were like, okay, now it's cool to have a podcast. And it's been like one of our favorite things we get to do together because I do it. They're my two best friends and I get to do it with them. That's amazing.
启发了我和戴夫以及他的妻子去开办一个播客。我们有一个播客。哦，太棒了。你们真的启发了我们去这样做，因为我们之前觉得，哦，播客太蠢了。然后一旦我们看到你们这样做了，我们就觉得，好吧，现在开办一个播客很酷。这已经成为了我们最喜欢一起做的事情之一，因为我在做。他们是我最好的两个朋友，我和他们一起做这件事。太棒了。
That's great. That's great. It was very nice to be to come on this one. Yeah, dude, so good. So, so good. You guys are rad, man. Yeah. Thank you guys so much.
太棒了。太棒了。很高兴能上这个节目。对啊，老弟，太棒了。太，太棒了。你们太酷了，伙计。对。非常感谢你们。
All right. Give our love to Selena. All right. I will. We'll talk soon. Okay. Bye, bye, bye, bye, bye, bye. See you when you're back.
好啦。代我们向赛琳娜问好。好啦，会的。我们很快再聊。好啦。拜，拜，拜，拜，拜，拜。等你回来见。
Text you soon. Bye, buddy. Text me that number, Willie. Yeah, I will. I love that threat. I love that threat. If we don't call him, he's going to air us out on Howard Stern. I just texted him first.
回头给你发短信。再见，老兄。把那个号码发短信给我，威利。对，我会的。我喜欢这个威胁。我喜欢这个威胁。如果我们不打电话给他，他就会在霍华德·斯特恩的节目里曝光我们。我刚刚先给他发了短信。
That's great, shoot. That's a nice fella. Real nice. I like him a lot. What a story. I mean, like inspiring. like, you know, we talk about it a lot on here, but it is all about baby steps to get to the thing you want,
太棒了，天哪。真是个好人。真的很好。我很喜欢他。多棒的故事。我的意思是，真振奋人心。就像，你知道的，我们在这里经常讨论这个，但要实现你想要的东西，全靠脚踏实地的小步前进，
and anybody can get there. You just have to put the work in, right? Yeah, it seems like he's already lived like a long lifetime. I know. He's 38. He's got, like, he was talking about vibe and stuff, like, he's got great vibe. He's got a great thing with people,
任何人都能成功。你只需要付出努力，对吧？对，感觉他好像已经经历了漫长的一生。我懂。他38岁了。他拥有，就像，他谈论氛围之类的事情，他有极好的氛围。他对人有一套，
and he under, like, there's something about him, and you combine that with the hard work and a true sort of talent for music and ear and all that sort of stuff and it's just a winning a winning combo. I want to hang out with him. I know.
而且他懂得，就像，他身上有某种特质，你把这与辛勤工作以及真正的音乐天赋、乐感以及诸如此类的一切结合起来，这就是一个无敌的组合。我想和他一起出去玩。我知道。
Well, wasn't there a hang that I missed that you guys were at? On Sunday or something, maybe? No, maybe... Might have been while you were both out. I was out of town for 71 days. Can you be more specific? Oh, boy.
嗯，不是有个聚会我错过了，你们当时都在吗？周日还是什么时候，也许？不，也许……可能是在你们俩都不在的时候。我离城71天。你能说得具体点吗？哦，天哪。
Well, you served your time, Willie, and now you learned your lesson, I think, right? But it just goes to... I mean, his books coming out, but I was going to say, like, he achieved it all, But you were saying it's all just baby steps, right? And then you do those, and then once you get through those, it's...
好吧，你已经服刑期满，威利，现在你吸取了教训，我想，对吧？但这只是说明……我的意思是，他的书要出版了，但我想说的是，他这一切都取得了成功，但你刚才说这都只是小步前进，对吧？然后你完成了这些，一旦你熬过了这些，它就是……
Bye, bye, bye, baby. Bye, bye, bye, bye. Bye. Bye. Right. Smartless is 100% organic and artisanly handcrafted by Michael Grant Terry, Rob Aramcharv. and Bennett Barbico. Smart less. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
拜，拜，拜，宝贝。拜，拜，拜，拜。拜。拜。对。Smartless是100%有机且由迈克尔·格兰特·泰瑞、罗布·阿兰查夫和班内特·巴尔比科手工匠心制作的。Smart less。这个单集目前还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。